learn how to build a sales management
application in this comprehensive sync
fusion course from gavin lawn gavin has
decades of experience that he brings to
his courses and think fusion provided a
grant that made this course possible hi
i'm gavin lon i've been developing
software professionally for over 20
years and i'm especially excited to
bring you this free course where we are
going to use the sophisticated sync
fusion components and we are going to
build a blazer server application on net
six the components are highly
customizable and are fine-tuned for
performance when dealing with high
volumes of data
so please join me as we develop a blazer
application where we'll integrate the
sophisticated syncfusion components into
our application and we'll also integrate
microsoft identity into our application
syncfusion provides a ui component suite
for building powerful web desktop and
mobile apps
essential studio is a software package
provided by syncfusion that provides
state-of-the-art solutions for startups
and enterprises it includes more than
1700 components and frameworks for
winforms wpf asp.net web forms mvc core
uwp win ui
xamarin flutter blazer javascript
angular vue and react that make
developers work easier
please join me in this free course
where we are going to build a real world
sales management application using
blazer during this course we are going
to integrate some of the most popular
syncfusion components in our blazer
application like the data grid the list
view
the charts
the diagram
the scheduler and more
laser is a web framework for building
web ui components razer components that
can be hosted in different ways razer
components can run server side in
asp.net core blazer server versus client
side in the browser on a web assembly
for the application that we are going to
develop
we are going to use the blazer server
hosting model
we will first develop the logic for each
razor component where we will learn how
we are able to harness the power and
sophistication of the sync fusion
components that we'll integrate into our
application through the implementation
of minimal amounts of code
toward the end of the course we'll
integrate login registration
authentication and authorization
functionality into our blazer server
application using microsoft identity
when an employee logs on to the sales
management application they'll be able
to access a personalized dashboard
where these beautiful sync fusion charts
will be displayed presenting the user
with data of relevance to the logged on
employee for example a sales manager
will see sales metrics related to
overall performance for the sales
department
a team leader will see sales metrics
related to the sales performance of each
of the team leaders team members
the sales rep will see metrics related
to the sales reps personal sales
performance
so if you go through this course with me
i can guarantee you you are going to
learn a tremendous amount about creating
a sophisticated web application using
blazer sync fusion components and
microsoft identity
so let me tell you more about the
application that we are going to build
using blazer server and the sync fusion
components
i've created a fictional company that
i've named outdoor excellence or oexl
for short this company sells outdoor and
sporting goods to retail outlets
situated around the united states
the application is specifically for the
sales department
that consists of a sales manager
team leaders that report to the sales
manager and sales reps that report to
their team leader
the sales reps are on the road most of
the time visiting clients and
facilitating orders made by the clients
for products sold by outdoor excellence
our application will provide an ordering
facility where a sales rep can for
example order multiple products from the
outdoor excellence product catalog
displayed through our blazer application
using the sync fusion list view
component the sales rep could for
example order multiple products through
our application using a mobile device
while in a meeting with a client
a team leader or the sales manager can
view their own personal dashboards and
view analytical data displayed using
syncfusion charts through our
application so bob jones the sales
manager could log in for example from
his office on his desktop computer and
view metrics beautifully displayed to
him in the relevant sync fusion charts
that have been integrated into our
application bob jones can then use these
sales metrics for decision making and
strategic planning
if for example olivia mills a sales rep
places a large order through the system
bob jones can see in real time the
effect that the order has on current
sales metrics through his personalized
dashboard each sales rep can view their
own personal dashboard when they log on
to the system
custom reports regarding their personal
performance is available through the
data expressed on these sophisticated
charts provided by syncfusion a team
leader is interested in the performance
of the team leaders team members and is
able to log on to the application
perhaps at a desktop computer in the
team leader's office
and can see in real time how each team
member is performing
these charts communicate at a glance how
the team is performing overall as well
as how each individual team member is
performing relative to the other team
members
bob jones the sales manager has
administrative permissions and is able
to perform crud create read update
delete operations on employee data
this functionality is facilitated using
the syncfusion data grid
bob jones is also able to view the
employee organizational hierarchy of his
sales department
this display is facilitated through the
use of the syncfusion diagram component
so through the system bob jones can for
example using the syncfusion data grid
change which team leader a sales rep
reports to
and the change is reflected immediately
within the syncfusion diagram depicting
the employee organizational hierarchy
bob can of course also add new employees
to the system using this facility
you can also change basic information
associated with employees like for
example changing someone's last name if
for example the relevant employee gets
married
the data grid provides bob with
conveniences like for example a search
facility
sorting functionality for each column
and he can also easily export the data
displayed on the data grid into other
common application formats for example
he can export the relevant data to an
excel spreadsheet or a pdf document
each employee is able to create
appointments within the sales management
application using this functionality
implemented through the integration of
the sync fusion scheduler component
for example a sales rep can create an
appointment in the system to meet a new
client at a specific date and time and
for a specific duration extra
information about the meeting can also
be saved for each appointment
a team leader for example is able to
create appointments within the
application
for meetings with team members
as with all the syncfusion components
the scheduler
is highly customizable
all of the technologies that we'll use
to build our sales management
application for outdoor excellence can
be downloaded free of charge
links have been included in the
description of this video to the
locations of where you can download and
install the relevant technologies
we'll be using visual studio 2022
community edition for windows as our ide
integrated development environment to
develop the application we'll develop
the application on.net 6.
you can download and install visual
studio from this location free of charge
we'll be using sql server 2019
as our back-end storage facility
you can download sql server 2019 from
this location
on occasion we'll be using sql server
management studio or ssms to update our
data and you are able to download ssms
from this location
note that even if you don't have a sync
fusion license you'll be able to follow
along with this course
but if you want to use the syncfusion
components to develop commercial
applications
you will need a valid license
you are able to claim a free syncfusion
community license by clicking this link
here and then following the appropriate
steps
in order to claim your free community
license you'll need to have a valid
linkedin or zing account
the community license allows you to use
syncfusion's entire product line free of
charge in your commercial applications
if you own the intellectual property of
the relevant applications the community
license is a complimentary license model
that is reserved for organizations
earning up to 1 million us dollars in
revenue and employing fewer than 5
developers
if this does not apply to you you will
need to get a paid license
please navigate to this url to learn
more about syncfusion's hassle-free
licensing model
in order to install the syncfusion
components during the development of our
application we'll use the new get
package manager from within visual
studio to download and install the
relevant syncfusion packages when we are
ready to integrate the relevant
syncfusion components into our
application
although we are developing the
application on a windows os our
application will be cross-platform and
we'll be able to run on most browsers
i will be using the chrome browser for
running the code interactively through
visual studio
so let's fire up visual studio 2022 and
get started with the development of our
sales management blazer application
let's click the create new project
option here
so we can already see the project
template we are going to use but visual
studio does allow us to filter our
project templates if we need to search
for a specific project template
so for our purposes we are going to
select blazer server app
let's name our project sales management
app and make sure we are saving our
project to an appropriate local
directory
let's click the next button
here we have dot net 6 already selected
as our version of dot net
so we don't have to change the setting
for the authentication type we could at
this point choose for example individual
accounts
and at this stage in the development of
our project integrate microsoft identity
into our application
for the purpose of the facilitation of
login registration
authentication and authorization
functionality
for now we are going to leave this
setting at none and toward the end of
the development of our application we'll
integrate microsoft identity into our
blazer server application
we are going to start with the
integration of the datagrid syncfusion
component into our blazer server
application
we can use the sophisticated
functionality within this component to
perform crowd operations paging grouping
sorting filtering searching exporting
the data displayed in the data grid to
an excel spreadsheet and much more
so let's install the syncfusion data
grid component
we can do this by installing the
appropriate new get package like this
so let's right-click the dependencies
node within our solution explorer window
click manage new get packages
we can then enter text that will help
the search facility find the sync fusion
grid nuget package that we can install
for a blazer application
this package contains the syncfusion
data grid component
and there it is the package that we want
to install syncfusion.blazer.grid
so at the time of the creation of this
video for this section of the course
the latest version of the
syncfusion.blazer
component is version 20.1.0.58
so let's click the install button
and we have successfully installed the
syncfusion.blazer.grid new get package
excellent
if you'd like to read more about getting
started with the syncfusion blazer data
grid component
please navigate to this url
where syncfusion provides comprehensive
information regarding getting started
with the syncfusion blazer datagrid
component
i will of course also take you through
the getting started process step by step
in this course
we also need to install the
syncfusion.laser dot themes new get
package so let's do this
and the other new get package that we
need to install
is the syncfusion.blazer.core
nuget package
excellent
so next let's open the program.cs file
within our sales management app project
and let's include the necessary
registration code here for using blazer
sync fusion components within our blazer
application
we have a red squiggly line under add
sync fusion blazer
to get rid of this let's bring in the
syncfusion.blazer namespace
great
we can register our community sync
fusion license using this line of code
within the program.cs class like this
you will need to of course replace the
your license text here with your
personal license key
note that you will be able to follow
along with this course without a license
but in order to use the syncfusion
products commercially you will need a
valid license
so next we need to open our
underscorelayout.cshtml
file
that resides within the pages folder
we need to add this line of code that
references a bootstrap 5 css file
and we also need to add this line of
code that references a javascript file
so we are ready to use the syncfusion
blazer datagrid component within our
blazer application
as stated syncfusion provides
comprehensive documentation for example
the getting started section of the
documentation pertaining to the
syncfusion blazer data grid contains the
instructions that we have just carried
out
for the integration of the syncfusion
blazer datagrid component on.net 6.
instructions regarding other versions of
net are also available
within the pages directory let's create
a new razer component named
employeemanagement.razer
let's provide routing information at the
top of our razer file using the add page
directive
within this shared directory let's open
the nav menu razer component which
houses the functionality for our
applications main menu the nav menu
razer component is provided to us by
default through the blazer server app
project template
let's add a navigation link to our
application's main menu
that when clicked invokes our employee
management razer component
and of course now when we run our code
interactively through visual studio we
are able to invoke
the employee management razer component
by clicking the appropriate link that we
have created within the nav menu razer
component
let's create a using directive at the
top of our file
that references the
syncfusion.blazer.grids namespace
we can now directly reference the types
that reside within this namespace within
our razor component without flagging a
compile time error
so let's include the data that we are
going to wire up to our syncfusion
datagrid component
to quickly get started using the
datagrid i've prepared a list of
employee records that we can include
within our razer component
in a bit we'll create a sql database
through ef core code first migrations
and then we'll wire up the relevant data
retrieved from the relevant database
table to our syncfusion datagrid
component
let's first create a class named
employee model that represents the shape
of the data for an employee record
to save time i've prepared this class
off screen
you can either type out the class or to
save time you can simply navigate to
this url where you can copy the employee
model class from the relevant github web
page and paste the class into your razer
file
a link to the relevant github web page
is available in the description of this
video
so the employee model class consists of
seven properties
id as integer first name as string last
name as string job title as string
gender as string date of birth as date
time and reports to empid as a nullable
integer
the question mark at the end of the int
data type definition denotes that this
integer property can store a null value
let's declare a private variable to
store a generic list that is strongly
typed with our employee model
user-defined type
let's override the blazer built-in
lifecycle event handler method named
uninitialized this method is invoked
when the component is ready to start
having received its initial parameters
from its parent in the render tree
so off screen i've prepared the code for
populating our list of employee model
data
you can copy the code that populates the
relevant list of employee records from
the relevant github web page
as stated a link to this github web page
is available below in the description of
this video
the data consists of made up employee
records
so now we are ready to create the code
for displaying our data to the screen
from within our razer component
so let's create the bare minimum code we
need to achieve this
so let's include a syncfusion data grid
component within our razor component by
adding a sf grid element
that represents our data grid here
now all we need to do is wire up the
data in our employee data list to the sf
grid component
to do this we can include a property
within the sf grid element named
datasource and set its value to the
variable named employee data that has
been assigned the list of employee model
data
let's run the code
and look at that right out of the box
our employee data is neatly displayed
within our syncfusion datagrid component
it is that simple we have achieved this
through a tiny amount of code that is
both easy to implement and easy to read
and the datagrid component adapts its
size based on the html element in which
it is contained
we can include or exclude the properties
we want displayed on our data grid by
including the grid columns element
within the sf grid parent element and
then including certain grid column
elements within the grid columns element
each grid column element represents a
property
within the class that represents an
employee record i.e denoted by the
employee model class
we can use the field property within
each grid column element to map employee
model properties to their appropriate
grid column element
so the data grid will now only include
those fields within the relevant data
source that have an appropriate grid
column element declared as a child
element within the grid column's parent
element
so you can already get a feel for how
easy it is to customize the sync fusion
data grid
we can set the width of each column by
adjusting the width property of the
relevant grid column element
we can then customize the heading text
for each column by appropriately
including a header text property within
the relevant grid column elements
excellent
we can customize our sync fusion
datagrid component so that the data
displayed is displayed over a number of
pages
to achieve this we simply set the sf
grid elements allow paging property to
true
and include a reference to the grid page
settings element within the sf grid
element like this
we can then assign a value representing
the number of rows per page we want
displayed within our data grid by
assigning the relevant value to the page
size property like this
so we are telling the syncfusion data
grid as it were
that we want to display five rows of
data per page on our data grid
the sophisticated functionality is
created with a few lines of declarative
code that is innately easy to read
to customize the maximum amount of rows
we want displayed on each page it is as
simple as appropriately assigning
our custom page size value to the
relevant page size property
excellent
if we had for example thousands of rows
of data we would definitely need a way
to search the relevant data we just need
to tell the syncfusion data grid
component as it were to include search
functionality in order to achieve this
we simply create a list which contains
the string value of search
so let's create a private variable named
toolbar then assign the private variable
a list of objects of course a string is
an object so we can include a list item
that is the string value search
we can then let the datagrid component
know as it were what functionality we
wish to include on the datagrids toolbar
to do this we can assign our list of
objects stored in our toolbar variable
to a property named toolbar within the
sf grid element
it's that simple we now have search
functionality
excellent
if we want to allow the user the ability
to group by any column all we need to do
is set the allow grouping property
within the sf grid element to true
in order to group by a particular field
the user can simply drag the column
header that represents the column by
which the user wishes to group the data
grid to this panel that is now available
on the data grid and our data is
appropriately grouped by our chosen
column and look at that we have grouped
by the reports column
and the data grid shows who each
employee reports to in the
organizational structure
you can group by many columns so let's
also group the data by gender
great
we are able to filter each column by
appropriately setting the allow
filtering property to true
we could run the code and we would be
able to filter each column by a text
input field provided for each column
we can include more sophisticated
filtering functionality for each column
by including a grid filter settings
element within the sf grid element we
can then include a type property within
the grid filter settings element and set
the type property to for example
syncfusion.blazer.grids.filtertype.menu
this provides a user the ability to
filter each column using a variety of
different types of criteria
for example a user can filter a column
by a value that the user specifies for
field values that start with a
user-specified string value
a user can specify that the user wishes
to filter the data based on field values
that are equal to a value that the user
specifies
a user can filter the data based on
values
in the data that are greater in value
than the user's specified value for
example the user may wish to filter the
data by employees born after 1990.
with this functionality the user can
filter the data in a variety of
different ways where a combination of
filters can be applied to multiple
columns
the user is able to clear filters from
certain columns
and try various combinations of
user-specified filtering criteria
very powerful indeed
and look at how simple the code is for
achieving such powerful results
in order for the user to be able to sort
by the columns in descending or
ascending order all we need to do is set
the allow sorting property within the sf
grid element to true like this
we are going to delve deeper into using
the syncfusion data grid to facilitate
crowd operations but at this point i'll
demonstrate the very basics of how to
customize the syncfusion data grid so
that it provides the user with a
facility whereby the user is able to
perform crowd operations on the relevant
data
of course we haven't yet created a
database in which we can store our data
so we are not able to persist data to a
database
we can however at this point
superficially demonstrate the relevant
crud operations within memory data
so to allow for the facilitation of
crowd operations using our syncfusion
data grid component let's include the
grid edit settings element within the sf
grid element like this
to allow for add operations or in crud
terminology create functionality
we set a property within the grid edit
settings element named allow adding to
true
then to include the appropriate toolbar
buttons
we can add the appropriate items to our
toolbar like this
so here we are telling the syncfusion
datagrid component as it were
that we wish to include the add update
and cancel buttons within the datagrids
toolbar
and we can now add records to our data
grid by clicking the add button
the user is then able to enter the
relevant data for the fields for the
record
that the user wishes to add to the data
grid
then the user can press the update
button to save the data to the data grid
and we can now see
that a new row containing the data that
we have just added
is present within the data grid
of course we are only dealing with
in-memory data at this stage
so if for example we navigate to another
component and then back to our employee
management component
the data that we added to the data grid
is no longer present within the data
grid to achieve the functionality of
persisting the added data to a database
through the data grid we will need to
further customize the data grid and of
course implement code to save the data
to a data storage facility like for
example sql server
and this is exactly what we are going to
do in just a bit
once we have pressed the add button the
update button and the cancel button are
enabled
so we could press the cancel button to
cancel the add operation
or once we have entered valid data into
the relevant fields we can press the
update button to save the relevant data
to the data grid
we can allow the records denoted by the
rows of employee data in our data grid
to be edited by including the allow
editing property within the grid edit
settings element and setting the allow
editing property to true
let's also include an appropriate edit
item within the toolbar list
so a user can now select the row in the
data grid that the user wishes to edit
then press the edit button on the
toolbar
carry out the relevant edit operations
and then press the update button to save
the relevant changes to the data grid
and the update functionality is
currently not working
in order for the edit operation to run
correctly we need to ensure that one of
the columns serves as a primary key
value
so let's add the is primary key property
to the grid column element that is wired
up to the id field
and let's set the is primary key
property to true
this allows for each record to be
uniquely identifiable within the data
grid
note that the user is also able to put a
particular row within the data grid into
edit mode by simply double clicking on
the relevant row
we can also as it were tell the sync
fusion data grid to include delete
functionality within the syncfusion data
grid by including the allow deleting
property within the grid edit settings
element and setting the allow deleting
property to true
we can then include a delete button
within the datagrids toolbar
by including the delete item within the
toolbar list like this
right so let's build the sales
management application
let's take a brief look at a depiction
of the relational database design for
our applications database
i've designed the structure of this
database
based on a process called normalization
let's look at a brief explanation of
what normalization is
here is a brief description provided by
wikipedia regarding the process of
normalization
database normalization is the process of
structuring a relational database in
accordance with a series of so-called
normal forms in order to reduce data
redundancy and improve data integrity
a link has been included below in the
description if you'd like to learn more
about database normalization
so if we look at a relational database
design depiction for our sales
management application
you can see that our database will
contain the following database tables
our database will contain the employees
table the employee job titles table
a products table a product categories
table an orders table and order items
table
a clients table a retail outlets table
and lastly we have a table named sales
order reports
the sales order reports table will be
the table that is used for storing
analytical data
the data stored in this table will be
used for the charts that will be
presented to the users of our
application on their dashboards
in terms of design this table can be
seen as different from the other tables
because this table has been deliberately
denormalized
i discuss why this table is denormalized
and what it means for a database table
to be denormalized when we write the
syncfusion charts related functionality
very basically denormalized database
tables are often used to store
analytical data
and normalize database tables are used
to store transactional data
transactional database tables are
generally written to more often than the
tables used to store analytical data
the denormalized tables are designed to
increase the retrieval speed of the data
stored within them
this increased speed is made possible
because of the elimination of the need
to join tables together when retrieving
the relevant data
so a major part of the denormalization
process is eliminating the need for
joins
so let's look at the normalized tables
and their relationships
the employees table has a many-to-one
relationship with the employee job
titles table many employees can have a
particular job title for example many
employees can have a job title of sales
rep
the products table has a many to one
relationship with the product categories
table
many products can fall under a
particular product category for example
a tent falls under the camping product
category and an air mattress
also falls under the camping product
category
the orders table has a one-to-many
relationship with the order items table
and order consists of many order items
the orders table has a many-to-one
relationship with the employees table
each order is created through a sales
rep a particular sales rep can create
many orders
the orders table has a many to one
relationship with the clients table many
orders can be made by a particular
client
the clients table has a one-to-one
relationship with the retail outlets
table the retail outlets table contains
details about the retail outlet itself
for example information about the retail
outlets location
each retail outlet has a person who
serves as a contact within the relevant
retail outlet
the clients table contains information
like for example contact information
about the person that serves as a sales
reps contact
a particular product can be associated
with many orders
so that was just a brief explanation of
my thinking behind the design for the
database that we are going to use for
our sales management application
as we get further into building our
application more details regarding how
the database design underpins the logic
for our application will emerge
so we are going to use ef core code
first migrations to build our database
at this stage we are focusing on
integrating the syncfusion datagrid
component for the purpose of
facilitating cred operations
so at this stage we only need to create
the employees table and the employee job
titles table
so let's create a folder to house the
entities that will represent our
database tables let's name the new
folder entities
let's add a c-sharp class to this new
folder named employee this employee
class can be viewed as a template that
represents a row in the employee's
database table each property that is
defined within the employee class and
each property's data type will
correspond to a column within the
employees database table
let's create an auto implemented
property named id
an easy way to create a property within
visual studio is to type prop then hit
the tab key twice and a default property
definition is generated for us by visual
studio we can then adjust the property
definition for example the properties
data type and the property's name
according to our requirement
for convenience you are able to navigate
to the elements of the property
definition using the tab key
so we are able to for example change the
property type and then use the tab key
to move the cursor to the property name
and we are then able to modify the
property name
so id as int
first name as string
last name as string
email as string
gender as string
date of birth as date time
and reports to empid as a nullable
integer
the question mark character following
the ins data type definition means that
this property can store a null value
the employees table supports a parent
child relationship
the reports to empid field will contain
either a null value or one of the values
stored in the id field which is the
primary key for the employees database
table
the relationship between the id field
and the reports to empid denotes the
following
if for example an employee with an id of
2
has a report to empid value of 1
this means the employee with the id
value of 2 reports directly to the
employee with an id value of 1. this
denotes that the employee with the id of
1 is the immediate boss of the employee
with the id of two within the
organizational structure
an employee with a report to empid of
null does not report to any other
employee and is therefore at the top of
the organizational structure in this
case that employee is the sales manager
bob jones
team leaders reports directly to bob
jones and sales reps report to a team
leader
so we are able to express the
hierarchical structure of the
organization for the employee data
stored in our employees table by
including a column that can store a null
value and can also store a value that
corresponds to the table's primary key
which in this case is the id field if
this concept is not clear to you don't
worry this will become clearer to you
when we integrate the syncfusion diagram
into our application later on in this
course in order to express our employee
data in a hierarchical depiction i.e a
structure that represents the
organizational structure of our
fictional sales department
let's create a string property named
image path its corresponding field in
the database will store a path to a
profile image of the relevant employee
i've prepared a profile image for each
employee
i'll supply the relevant details of
where you can download the profile
images a little bit later when necessary
we'll add data for each employee to the
employees database table and employee
job titles database table a little bit
later
lastly let's create an integer property
named employee job title id
this field will serve as the foreign key
field
from the employee job titles database
table
the employee job titles for our
application are as follows the sales
manager or sm for short the team leader
or tl for short and the sales rep
or sr for short
so each employee will have one of these
three job titles in our fictional sales
department
let's create a class that will
correspond to the employee job titles
database table
let's name this class employee job title
let's create the first field which must
be named employee job title id
this is the primary key field that joins
this table with the foreign key field of
the same name in the employees table
let's create a string property named
name
and let's create a string property named
description
great
right let's create our database using
entity framework core code first
migrations
in order to do this through visual
studio we need to install two nuget
packages let's include the nuget package
named microsoft dot entity framework
core dot sql server
great
and let's install the new get package
named microsoft dot entity framework
core dot tools by installing the
microsoft dot entity framework
core.tools nuget package
we'll be able to for example create our
database migrations by running the
relevant commands within the new get
package manager console window from
within visual studio we wouldn't need to
install this package if we were to run
the relevant migration commands through
the.net sdk
note that when using the.net sdk for
running ef core migration commands the
commands are different to when running
the commands for the same purpose
through visual studio
for this course we are going to run the
relevant migration commands directly
through visual studio which means an
installation of the microsoft dot entity
framework core.tools new get package is
necessary
in order to build our database using ef
core we must include a db context class
within our application
this dbcontext class is essential for
when we need to retrieve or modify data
in our database using code within our
application
so let's create a class to represent our
db context within the data folder
let's name our class sales management db
context
this class must inherit from the db
context base class
the red squiggly line under db context
is visual studio indicating to us
that we are missing a using directive
an easy way to include the relevant
namespace directive
is to press ctrl period
and then visual studio presents us with
a context menu
we can select the top menu item in this
case and the relevant using directive is
added to the top of our code
so the db context type resides within
the microsoft dot entity framework core
namespace
great
let's create a constructor for our
dbcontext class
an easy way to generate a default
definition for a constructor for a
c-sharp class from within visual studio
is to type in ctor
and then press the tab key twice
this constructor must accept an argument
of the generic type db context options
that is strongly typed with our sales
management db context type
we must pass this argument down to a
constructor within the db context base
class by using the base keyword like
this
and now all we need to do is tell ef
core as it were about the classes that
we wish to use as definitions for our
database tables
so to do this we include a property of
the generic data type db set for each
table that we wish to generate within
our database
we must strongly type each db set
property with the appropriate user
defined type that we have used to define
the relevant database tables in our
entities folder
so the first property is defined with
the generic db set type that has the
employee user defined type passed to it
as a type argument
so the second property is defined with
the generic db set type that has the
employee job title user-defined type
passed to it as a type argument
each of these property names will be
used as the database table names for the
corresponding tables in the database
so when we create a migration and update
the database the database will be
created and two database tables will be
created within our database one named
employees and the other named employee
job titles the next step is to ensure
that we have an appropriate connection
string defined within the
appsettings.json file
so to do this let's create a connection
string setting within our
appsettings.json file
and create a connection string named
sales management db connection
so we need to set the server property of
our connection string to the server name
on which our database will be created my
server name is gavinlon's pc
we must then set the database property
of the connection string to the name of
the database we wish to create
sales management db seems like a
sensible
name then set the trusted underscore
connection property to true this
basically means that the windows account
under which our application runs will be
authenticated against the relevant sql
server database
great the next step is to register our
sales management db context type for
dependency injection
we can do this by including the
appropriate code within the program.cs
file
so let's open the program.cs file
let's first write code to read the
relevant connection string from our
appsettings.json configuration file into
memory
let's then use the add db context method
to register our db context class ie our
sales management db context type
for dependency injection
here we are configuring our db context
type to use a sql server database and
the necessary details of the relevant
sql server database have been defined
within the relevant connection string
that we are passing to the use sql
server method here
great
so we are now ready to run the relevant
ef core commands to generate our
database
to do this let's invoke the package
manager console window like this
to create a migration we can type the
add dash migration command and then
follow this command with the name of our
migration class
let's name this migration initial create
let's press the enter key to run the
command
and our migration class has been
generated for us
you can see that the up method contains
code that builds the database and the
database tables that we have defined
within the sales management db context
class
the down method contains code to undo
the effects of the code that resides
within the up method
so we have created our migration
but we have not yet run the code within
the up method that will generate our sql
server database
with the database tables that we have
defined within our sales management db
context class ie through the properties
defined as the db set generic type so in
order to run our migration we must type
in the update database command
let's open sql server management studio
to see if our database has been created
excellent our sales management db
database has been created successfully
and we can see that the employees
database table has been created and the
employee job titles database table has
also been created within the sales
management db sql server database
so i've prepared data for our employees
and employee job titles tables off
screen
we are going to seed these database
tables by using the code that i've
prepared off screen
to do this let's create a static class
within the data folder named seed data
let's create a static void method within
our seed data static class named add
employee data as stated i've prepared
code that will add the relevant employee
data and employee job title data to the
relevant database tables
and this code can be copied from a
github web page at this url
let's copy the code from the relevant
github web page
and paste the code within our add
employee data method
let's bring in the sales management app
dot entities namespace
let's include a parameter within the add
employee data method named model builder
which is of the type model builder we
must also bring in the microsoft.entity
framework namespace which is where the
model builder type resides
so in order to seed our employees table
and employee job titles table
with the data we have defined within the
seeddata.addemployeedata method we must
first override a method defined in the
dbcontext base class
an easy way to override a method within
visual studio is to type override
then hit the spacebar key a list of
overrideable methods is presented to us
by visual studio
and on model creating is the list item
we want so let's select on model
creating
then within the on model creating method
let's call the seed data dash add
employee data method
and pass in the relevant model builder
object to the add employee data method
like this
great
so to seed our database tables with data
we can now open the package manager
console window
we can clear the screen by typing the
clear command and pressing enter
and we can then type in the add dash
migration command followed by a sensible
name for our migration so let's name our
migration seed employee data
and you can see ef core has generated
the code for seeding our database tables
so to run the code against our database
we can type in the update database
command and press enter
let's look at our data in sql server
management studio
excellent
let's create functionality to retrieve
data from within our employees database
table
and return the relevant data to eraser
component
we don't want to expose our entity
classes directly
to the razer components that are
responsible for presenting the relevant
data to the user
so we are going to create appropriate
model classes that will store the data
that is directly handled from within the
relevant razer components so by doing
this we are creating a separation of
concerns
the entity classes interact directly
with the database the ef core
functionality the model classes
are only concerned with the presentation
layer
and are handled by code within the
relevant razer components
so let's create a folder named models
let's create a class named employee
model
let's copy the properties from the
employee entity
class and paste the properties into our
employee model class
so at this stage we could implement the
repository pattern and wrap our database
related functionality in specially
created repository classes in the
interests of simplicity for this code
example we are going to abstract the
database handling code in our service
classes
we are not going to implement the
repository pattern in this course
you can of course implement the
repository pattern if you'd prefer i do
encourage creating distinct separation
of concerns and code
but this course is focused on the
integration of syncfusion components
into a blazer application so in the
interest of time i want to keep the
back-end related code fairly simple
let's create a new folder named services
so let's create our first service class
which will be responsible for handling
employee data
within the services folder let's create
a folder named contracts
let's create an interface within the
contracts folder named i employee
management service
let's create a definition for an
asynchronous method named get employees
that will be responsible for returning a
generic list
that is strongly typed with our employee
model user-defined type
let's write code to implement the i
employee management service interface
so we need to bring in the sales
management app dot services dot
contracts namespace
then with our mouse pointers positioned
appropriately we can press control
period again and generate code stubs for
the methods that must be implemented
like this
so at this point we only need to
implement code for one method the get
employees method
before we do this let's create a
constructor for our employee service
class
let's add a parameter to the constructor
of type sales management db context to
indicate to.net as it were that we want
an object of type sales management db
context injected into this constructor
at runtime so whenever an object is
instantiated from our employee
management service class
an object of type sales management db
context
will be injected into the relevant
employee management service object
so let's position our mouse pointers
appropriately press ctrl period and
select create and assign field sales
management db context from the menu that
is presented to us within visual studio
and this action results in visual studio
generating an appropriate private member
variable to store the object of type
sales management's db context that will
be injected into this constructor at
runtime during the instantiation process
of the employee service class
we can now use the relevance dbcontext
object to retrieve employee data from
our database with this line of code
so we have a red squiggly line
so we must bring in the microsoft dot
entity framework core namespace so that
we can include the to list async
extension method within our code here
but we still have a red squiggly line
this is because we want our method to
return a list of employee model objects
but we are currently attempting to
return a collection of employee objects
through our get employees method
so to solve this we could write link
transform code that converts our
collection of employee objects to a
collection of employee model objects
within the get employees method
and that would be fine
but in the interests of cleaner code
let's create a convert extension method
for this purpose
this means that we will be able to call
a method named convert
on the code that returns a collection of
employee entities and the code we are
about to implement for the convert
extension method will perform the
appropriate conversion functionality
so let's first create a folder named
extensions
within the extensions folder let's
create a static class named conversions
within the conversions static class
let's create a static async method named
convert that returns a list of employee
model objects
in order to make this method an
extension method that can be called on
an object of type i queryable that is
strongly typed as employee we need to
include a parameter that is of type i
queryable that is strongly typed with
the employee type and this parameter
must be preceded by this keyword
an extension method must contain at
least one parameter and the first
parameter in an extension method must be
of the type on which the extension
method is called the first parameter
must also be preceded by the this
keyword
if this isn't clear to you at this point
this will become clearer when we call
the extension method on the i queryable
object returned by our efcor code in the
get employees method
so let's implement the code for our
convert extension method
so we can now use the employee's object
passed as an argument to the convert
method
and through a link query we can perform
the appropriate transform operation ie
where we convert the i queryable object
that is strongly typed with the employee
type i.e this is a collection of
employee objects returned from the
database
into a list that is strongly typed with
the employee model type
this is the list
that we want to return to the relevant
razor component that we'll create in a
bit
and now that our extension method is
created we can perform the necessary
conversion operation within our get
employees method cleanly
like this
and of course we have a red squiggly
line because we need to bring in the
sales management app dot extensions
namespace and that's it
our get employees method is ready for
use excellent
so now we want to write codes to wire up
our syncfusion datagrid component to the
employee data returned from our database
so let's open the
employeemanagement.razer file
let's remove the code related to the
static data that is currently wired up
to our sync fusion datagrid component
we now have a red squiggly line under
the employee model type
because that was a reference to the
employee model class
that has now been removed from our razor
file
so let's bring in our newly defined
employee model type
by pressing control period and selecting
the appropriate menu item represented to
us by visual studio
great
and we need to change the field property
value within our syncfusion data grid
code here
because the name in the newly defined
employee model for the job title field
is not job title
but is employee job title id
and for now let's remove code from our
data grid relating to crud operations
data filtering
sorting
grouping and paging
and for now we also don't need our data
grid to have a toolbar
let's write code to override blazers
built-in
uninitialized async lifecycle event
handler method
within our uninitialized async method
let's include code that gets the
employee data from our database using
our employee management service class
and we must first write code so that an
object of type employee management
service is injected into our razor
component at runtime
great
so let's write code to call the get
employees method on our employee
management service object and assign the
returned list of employee model objects
to our variable that we have named
employee data
the employee data variable is the data
source for our data grid syncfusion
component
let's run the code
and we have an error
okay and i know exactly what has caused
that exception
it is because we haven't registered the
employee management service type for
dependency injection
so let's open the program.cs class and
write the code to register the employee
management service type for dependency
ejection
so to do this
we can simply include this line of code
within the program.cs class
let's run the code again
and now the data stored within the
employees table within our newly created
sql server database
is being neatly displayed within our
syncfusion data grid component
excellent
let's explore the datagrid component
further
so we don't want the integer value
displayed for the employee job title id
field like it is being displayed at the
moment within our data grid
the employee job title id value
is great for the unique identification
of job titles
but is not ideal for presentation
purposes
we want the name of the job title to be
displayed here
because it is more human readable than
the employee job title id value
we also want an administrator to be able
to change the job title for an employee
if necessary
so we want this field to be able to
display a drop down list containing all
job titles as list items
when an administrator puts a row
displayed within the data grid in edit
mode
so
when in read mode
we want the name of the job title
displayed to the user but when an
administrator needs to change the job
title for a particular employee
we need the administrator
to have access to a drop-down list
containing all employee job title names
the job titles that exist in the system
at the moment are sales manager
team leader and sales rep
in the name field in the employee job
titles table
we are storing an abbreviation of these
job titles
sm for sales manager
tl for team leader and sr for sales rep
so for example if a sales rep is
promoted to a team leader
we want an administrator to be able to
change the employee's job title
from sr to tl
from within a drop down list
in the appropriate row in our data grid
so to achieve this let's first go to our
i employee management service interface
let's create a definition for a method
that returns a list of employee job
title objects
in the interests of time
i'm going to use the employee job title
class for the model and not create a
model dedicated for presentation
purposes like we did with the employee
model class
so let's go to the employee management
service class and implement the code for
our get job titles method
great let's go to our employee
management.razer file
let's create a variable to store a list
of employee job title objects
let's write code to call our get job
titles method on the employee management
service object from within our override
method
of the uninitialized async blazer
lifecycle method handler and we are
assigning the returned value to our
employee job title data
variable so the employee job titles
table has a one-to-many relationship
with the employees table and we are able
to as it were let the sync fusion data
grid component know about the
relationship through appropriate
declarative code that we are about to
create
the employee job title id field within
the employees table is a foreign key
from the employee job titles table
the employee job titles table has a
field that serves as its primary key
named employee job title id
we can as it were let the syncfusion
data grid component know about this
relationship between the employee job
title id primary key field in the
employee job title data data source and
the employee data data source
through appropriate declarative code
that we are about to write so to
establish the relationship between the
employee data data source
that we have already wired up to our
data grid and the employee job title
data data source that we are going to
wire up to the relevant drop down list
we are going to appropriately include a
component within the data grid named
grid foreign column
instead of using the grid column
component that we are currently using to
represent our columns so this will mean
that when a user selects a new value
from within the employee job titles drop
down list
that the employee job title id foreign
key value will automatically be changed
appropriately in the employee data data
source
so when the user changes an item within
the employee job titles drop down list
the employee job title id value mapped
to the selected drop drop-down list
will become the value reflected in the
employee data data source which is the
data source wired up to our data grid
through the declarative code that we are
implementing for our data grid we are
telling the syncfusion data grid as it
were
about the one-to-many relationship
between the employee job titles data
source wired up to the relevant
drop-down list and the employees data
source wired up to the sf grid component
so let's create the code for this
let's delete the grid column component
that is currently implemented to
represent the employee job title id
field
let's include a component named grid
foreign column to represent the employee
job title id field
as well as include the relevant
drop-down list that will contain the
employee job titles
let's set the header text property value
to designation
let's set the t value property to
employee job title
we are doing this because we want the
relevant drop down list to contain items
of type employee job title
we want the value of each item in the
drop-down list to have its primary key
value employee job title id
mapped to the foreign key value also
named employee job title id which is a
foreign key field included in the
employee model class
we must set the foreign data source
property to the data stored within the
employee job title data variable
this variable stores a list of employee
job title objects
we can then set the foreign key value
property to the property that we want
displayed to the user within the drop
down list which is the name property
let's make the fields width 100 pixels
so when a row is in edit mode
we want our drop down list to appear to
the user
to let the sync fusion grid component as
it were know about this we must
appropriately include the edit template
component in our code like this
within the edit template element we must
include the sf drop-down list component
let's bring in the appropriate namespace
for the sf drop-down list type which
resides in the
syncfusion.blazer.dropdowns
namespace
let's use the at bind dash value
attribute to bind the appropriate
employee model object's
employee job title id value to the value
selected within the relevant drop-down
list
each row in the data grid corresponds to
a list item of type employee model
stored within the employee data data
source for the data grid
we are able to access each rows list
item object
through an object named context
provided to us by the sync fusion data
grid
we can type cost the context object into
its underlying type in this case the
employee model type using the c sharp as
keyword like this
and then we can access the property that
we wish to bind to
let's set the id property of the sf
drop-down list component to employee job
title id
let's set the data source property to
the variable that stores the relevant
list of type employee job title
let's set the t item property to the
employee job title type
the relevant data source for our drop
down list contains a list of items of
type employee job title
the value that will be bound to the
employee data data sources employee job
title id property must be of type int so
let's set the t value property to end
and then within the sf drop down list
element
let's include a component named drop
down list field settings
let's set its text property to name and
its value property to employee job title
id
so the name property of the selected
item
will be displayed to the user in the
drop drop-down list and the value of the
selected item in the drop-down list
will be the selected objects which is of
type employee job title
employee job title id value
let's run the code
great so the name of the employee job
title is now appropriately displayed
within the relevant column
so we need to indicate that we want to
allow for a user to be able to edit rows
within the data grid so to do this we
simply include the grid edit settings
component within the sf grid element and
include a property
within the grid edit settings element
named allow editing and set its value to
true
let's run the code
and now when we double click a row
within our data grid which puts the
relevant row into edit mode we are able
to change the value for an employee's
job title through the use of an
appropriate drop down list excellent
you'll see later when we perform certain
cred operations on the data that the
drop down list values are automatically
mapped to the employee data data source
through the relationship between the
employee job titles employee job title
id field
the employee job titles database tables
primary key and the employees employee
job title id foreign key field
so let's also create a drop down list
for the gender field
we can implement the code for this using
an enum
so for this field we don't need to bind
a primary key value from one data source
to a foreign key value of another data
source as we have done for the employee
job title id field let's create an enum
named gender val and include the
appropriate enum list items
let's modify the grid column component
for the gender field so that a drop down
list containing the gender items can be
accessed from within the data grid when
a row is in edit mode
so let's first include the edit template
element within the relevant grid column
element so before we set the data source
property for the relevant sf drop-down
list element
let's write code that converts the
gender enum list items to an array of
string values
we can use the enum types get names
method for this purpose like this
then we can set the data source for the
relevant sf drop-down list component to
the variable that stores the appropriate
string array values
we can then tell the sync fusion data
grid as it were about the type
of collection that we want contained
within the relevant drop-down list
so in this case each item contained
within the drop-down list is of type
string
so we set the t item property to string
and the value for each item will also be
a string
so we can set the t value property to
string as well
lastly we must set the at bind value
attribute
to the correct property within the
employee model type which is of course
the gender property
we can access the relevant employee
model object pertaining to the relevant
edited row
through the context object
that is made accessible to us by the
sync fusion datagrid component
let's run the code
great
we also want to include a drop down list
for the report to emp id field
in the relevant drop-down list for this
field we want to present a list of
employees
that are either a team leader
or the sales manager
so in effect we are excluding sales reps
from this list because no one in the
organization reports to the sales reps
firstly let's create a special model
within the models folder that represents
an employee that can be reported to as
it were
let's name the c-sharp class
report2model
so the first property is named report to
amp id and is a nullable integer
the reason this field is nullable is
because an employee might not
necessarily report to another employee
like for example bob jones who is the
sales manager
and is the head of the sales department
therefore doesn't report to anyone in
the sales department
then let's include a string property
named report to name
let's create a method definition for a
method named get report to employee
within the i
employee management service interface
for an asynchronous method that will be
responsible for retrieving a list of
objects of type report to model
let's implement the code for the get
reports to employee method within our
employee management service class
so let's create a link query
that returns a list of employee objects
so to do this we can join the employee
entities employee job title id foreign
key field to the employee job title
entities employee job title id primary
key field
so that we can explicitly filter the
data based on the names of the relevant
job titles in this case the names of the
job titles are sm
and tl
yes we could just use the report to id
key for this purpose
but i want it to be explicit regarding
the employees that need to be included
in the returned list based on their job
title
then we can assign the relevant returned
values to the appropriate properties of
the report to model type
so i'm assigning the report to name
property the employee's first name
followed by the first character of the
employee's last name just for clarity
then the way we wire up the code so that
the drop down list appropriately appears
for our reports to empid field
is very similar to the way in which we
implemented the code for the employee
job title id field
so let's first write the code to
retrieve the relevant data
now let's comment out the code for the
current grid column element
that is currently representing the
report to empid field
let's make a copy of the grid foreign
column element
that we created
for the employee job title id field
and paste it appropriately above the
code that we have just commented out
then let's change the settings
appropriately for our new grid foreign
column element
let's run the code
and we have an exception thrown and why
is that
it's because our scenario here is
slightly different to the implementation
for the employee job title id field with
the employee job title id field the
value can never be null
so the t value property here must be set
to end
for the report to empi d field the value
can be null which means we need to let
the syncfusion data grid know as it were
that this field can be null
so we need to set the appropriate t
value property here
to nullable end like this
remember employees don't necessarily
report to anyone
as is the case with bob jones who
reports to no one he is the sales
manager the head of the department
so we must make this field nullable
so this field can either be set to null
or an integer value
so that is why we are setting the t
value property here to c sharp's
nullable end data type
let's run the code
and that's great but how does an
administrator set the drop down list to
a null value
so to achieve this
we want to make a slight modification
for this special case
so let's go to the get report to
employees method within the employee
management service class
and add a list item
that represents a null value to the list
of report 2 model items returned from
this method
let's ensure that the null item appears
as the first option in our drop down
list
so let's order the list by the report to
empid property
let's run the code
excellent
so the null value is represented by the
text none which is wrapped in angle
brackets great
the syncfusion data grid is highly
customizable
for example we can include an image for
each employee record that can be
displayed within the data grid
we can also style the image
appropriately using css so i've prepared
some image files for this part of the
course
the image path field in the employees
table of our database has been seeded
with the appropriate image path for each
employee add points to the appropriate
image which must reside
within the www root slash images slash
profile folder
so let's create the images folder within
our www root folder
and then let's create the profile folder
within the images folder
please download the images from this
location on github
and then copy the images into the www
root slash images
slash profile
folder
great
so to include the employees profile
image within the data grid let's add a
grid column element
let's set the header text for our column
to profile
and let's set the width of our column to
120 pixels
we can include an image within this grid
column using the template element like
this
we are now able to appropriately include
html code within the template element
that will in effect display
the appropriate image within the
relevant data grid column note how we
are able to use razor code here
to access
the employee model object for each row
in the data grid
we are able to access the context object
for this purpose
we can then include the image path field
for the relevant employee model object
as the value
for the src attribute of the image html
element
that we are including within the
template element
and that's great the image is displayed
within the data grid but it could look a
lot better
we are able to customize the images
displayed within the relevant grid
column of our data grid using css
so you can see that i've included a css
class within the div element
that wraps the image element that is
used for displaying the relevant
employee profile image here
we are able to style the image
appropriately with basic css code
so to do this
let's create a style tag here
and let's add the dot profile dash image
dash container class here
let's set the width of the image
container div element to 80 pixels
and let's also set its height to 80
pixels
let's target the image element that is
responsible for displaying the profile
image
and set its width and height properties
so that the image fills its container
100 percent
let's say that we want our image to be
displayed within a circle
we can achieve this by setting the image
elements border radius property
to 50 pixels
let's run the
code excellent
and when we put a row in edit mode our
image does not display which is what we
want great this is because we haven't
wired up the relevant grid column
responsible for displaying the employee
profile image
using the field property to a property
within the employee model type
we are only displaying a small amount of
data within our data grid
but if we were displaying thousands of
records
it is a good idea to display a spinner
to the user while the records are
loading
this provides a better user experience
ux to the users of our application
to achieve this we can appropriately add
the sf spinner component to our data
grid like this
we can set the spinner components at
bind dash visible attribute to a boolean
property
that we will create in a bit
then we can control through this
property
that we have named visible prop
when the spinner is displayed to the
user and when the spinner disappears
let's set the visible prop property to
true
before code runs to retrieve relevant
data
and then to false once the execution of
the relevant code has completed
our code here is only retrieving a small
amount of data so let's introduce an
appropriate amount of latency to
simulate the delay for the retrieval of
a much larger amount of data
so let's create a delay of two thousand
milliseconds or two seconds
great
we are just using the default spinner
style here but please check out the sync
fusion documentation regarding the sf
spinner component
and you can see how you are able to
customize the style of the spinner in
many ways to suit your requirement
so we can now remove the artificial
latency that we have introduced within
the uninitialized async method
so earlier on in this course we looked
at the performance of crud create read
update delete operations facilitated by
the sync fusion data grid component
we can include such functionality by
simply adding a toolbar to the data grid
like this
we must also ensure that we have
included the grid edit settings element
within the sf grid element
then we can set the allow adding
property to true so that a user can add
employee records to the system through
the use of the data grid
the allow editing property has already
been appropriately included and is
already set to true which will enable a
user to edit employee records through
the use of the data grid
we must also appropriately include the
allow deleting property and set its
value to true so that a user can delete
employee records from the system through
the data grid
so a user can now perform crowd
operations through the use of our data
grid
but as we demonstrated earlier on in
this course
when we were only dealing with in-memory
data we were able to perform the
relevant crat operations and the changes
made through our crud operations were
reflected in the data grid which is
excellent
but in order to sustain the changes that
a user makes through the relevant crud
operations
done through the use of the data grid we
need to customize our data grid a bit
further
so for example when a user adds a new
employee record to the data grid we want
the new employee record to be inserted
into the employees database table
so we have now created our database so
we are now working with persistent data
which means we can create functionality
for our application so that when a user
performs crowd operations through the
use of the data grid the effects of the
crad operations are both reflected in
the data grid as well as appropriately
persisted to our database
sync fusion makes it easy for us
to hook into events that are triggered
by user actions performed on the data
grid and therefore we are able to
include our own custom code
appropriately within relevant event
handlers so that changes made by the
user through the use of the data grid
are appropriately saved to our database
so for example if a user clicks the add
button on the data grids toolbar then
fills in values for the relevant fields
and then clicks the update button on the
toolbar which means the user is saving
the relevant data to the data grid
our custom code can run at this point
and save the relevant data to a database
table
so
how do we hook into the relevant data
grid events
firstly let's create the custom code
necessary for adding a new record to our
database
so let's go to the i employee management
service interface and add a definition
for a method that will be responsible
for adding a record to the employees
database table
let's implement the logic for this
method within our employee management
service class
so before we do that let's create a
convert extension method so that the
employee model object passed into our
add method can easily be converted into
the employee type that can then be added
to our employees database table using
appropriate ef call functionality
notice here for the image path field
i'm setting the image for a newly added
employee to a default image which is
based on the employee's gender
then we can simply call the convert
method on the employee model object
passed into our add method we can then
use entity framework core functionality
to save the newly created record to our
employees database table
excellent
so now how can we run our code that we
have just created to add a new employee
to the employees database table based on
a user's action performed to add a new
employee record to the data grid
to achieve this
we are able to include a component named
grid events
within the sf grid element
then within the grid events element
we can set the on
action begin property to an event
handler method
that we'll create in a bit
where we can implement code to call the
add functionality that we have just
created within the employee management
service class
so let's create the method that will run
when a user performs an action on our
data grid
note that we are able to use
intellisense like this
where we can see the method signature or
method definition if you like
that we need to implement for our action
begin handler method ie the method that
we have assigned
to the onactionbegin property
we are able to use the args argument
passed to our event handler method when
a relevant action is performed by the
user on the data grid to assess the
exact nature
of the user's action
so we want to capture the event as it
were
when a user clicks the update button on
the toolbar in order to save new data to
the data grid
so we can do this by checking the data
available in the args argument like this
we can check the request type value on
the args object
we also want to further evaluate the
args data to check if the save action
occurred after the user performed an ad
operation
we can do this with this line of code
where we are checking if the args
argument action value is equal to add
so if these two conditions are met our
code knows as it were that the user is
performing a create operation the user
is adding data to the data grid
so we can include our create
functionality here where we can save a
newly added employee record to the
employees database table
so let's use our employee management
service functionality appropriately to
add a new record to the employees
database table
note that the data inputted by the user
is accessible through the args arguments
data value here
so we can pass this value to our add
employee method like this
before we act as a user and add a record
to the database
let's include the email field within our
data grid
we have not allowed this field to store
null values in our employees database
table
so a value for the email field must be
supplied when adding a new employee
record to the employee's database table
so let's adjust the data grid size to
accommodate our new column
so let's add a record to our database
through the data grid
so let's say a new sales rep named greg
ross has just joined the company
so let's add his details to the system
and he will report to team leader jenny
marks
great and greg ross has been
successfully added to the system
notice that the id value is zero at the
moment and no image is displayed for
greg ross at present
this is because we need to refresh the
data in the grid in order for the id
value related to the new employee greg
ross to be appropriately displayed on
the data grid
this is also true for greg ross's
profile image
to make sure our data grid is refreshed
with the latest data saved to the
database we can hook
into another event that fires once the
code to add an employee record has
completed
so to achieve this
let's set the on action complete
property to a method handler that we are
going to create in just a bit
let's name our event handler method
action complete handler
you can use intellisense to see what the
method signature or method definition
of our event handler method must be
so let's create the relevant event
handler method
we only want our custom code in this
case to execute
when the user has added a new record
let's use the appropriate if statements
to check the nature of the user's
actions
i am currently just checking the request
type value for the save action here
but we should also include code to check
that the action value is set to the
literal text add
as we have done in the action begin
handler method
we only want the grid to refresh as it
were once a user has added a new
employee record through the use of the
data grid
for the functionality of refreshing the
data grid we need to reference
our sync fusion datagrid component in
our code
to do this
we can use the at ref attribute and set
its value to a property that will store
a reference to our syncfusion datagrid
component
so let's create the property that will
reference the data grid in our code here
let's apply code to refresh the
datagrid's data source with the latest
employee data saved to the database by
assigning the data source property a
list of employee model objects returned
by the get employees method that is
called on the injected employee
management service object
and we can call the refresh method on
the property that references our
syncfusion data grid component like this
so currently when we put the data grid
into add mode the id field is editable
we can explicitly disable this field by
including the allow adding property
within the appropriate grid column
element and set its value to false
this is an auto-incremented field and we
don't want the user to edit this field
let's enable sorting for our data grid
we can achieve this by including the
allow sorting property within the sf
grid element and setting its property to
true
so if we add a new employee named david
brown to the system
the record has been added
and because our code is now refreshing
the data once the record has been added
the id for the employee
that we have just added will have the
highest id value in the data grid
so the data grid is currently being
sorted by id in ascending order the
newly added employee record for david
brown will currently occupy the last row
in the data grid
so because we have enabled sorting
the user can sort the id column in
descending order so we can now see the
newly added record at the top of the
data grid
the employee id saved to the employee's
database table is displayed in the data
grid and a default image is also
displayed for the newly added mail
employee
and you can see here that i've added a
few other records to the system
off-screen
so let's create the data handling
functionality for when a user updates
details for an employee record within
the data grid and let's also create the
functionality for deleting an employee
within our employee management service
class
let's create a method named update
employee
and implement the logic like this
let's create the logic for the delete
employee method like this
if at any point you get stuck and are
struggling to follow along please
reference the code on github you are of
course welcome to copy the code from the
relevant github page
great so within the action begin handler
method we can include a check to see if
an edit has occurred and then apply our
database related code appropriately here
so for the scenario where a user action
triggered the action begin handler
method and a save has not been initiated
by the user but rather a delete has been
initiated by the user we can include an
appropriate else if condition
in the top if block to check for a
delete action
we can then apply the appropriate code
to delete the relevant record from the
database like this
we only need the refresh functionality
to run when an ad action occurs so
please make sure that an if condition is
appropriately included within the action
complete handler method to check that an
ad action has been initiated so that the
data is only refreshed within the data
grid when a create operation has been
completed
let's run the code and test that our
update functionality has been
implemented correctly
excellent
and we are now able to create employee
records within the system
and update employee records within the
system using our sync fusion data grid
we can also delete records from the
system like this
the effects on the employee data caused
by user cred related actions
are now not only reflected in the data
grid but are also persisted to the
employees database table great
so
one thing of course we need to discuss
along with the subject of credit
operations is validation
so how can we enforce validation rules
for the fields of our data grid for when
a user is either attempting to add a new
record to the system or update an
already existing record in the system
this is very simple to do those of you
familiar with asp.net core razer pages
or mvc will no doubt already be familiar
with the code that can be implemented
here for this purpose
to enforce a specific validation rule on
a model's property a developer is able
to decorate the relevant models property
with a specific attribute that indicates
to.net as it were which validation rule
should be applied
to the relevant models property so let's
look at this with an example so each row
of data in our data grid is of type
employee model
so if we go to the employee model class
we can for example apply the required
attribute
and therefore the required validation
rule to the first name property like
this
the validation attributes reside within
the system.component model dot data
annotations namespace
so we must ensure
we include an appropriate using
directive at the top of our code
and if when we edit this field in our
data grid and we violate the required
rule a red border appears around the
relevant input field
and we are presented with an appropriate
error message
let's apply the required validation rule
for the last name field
the email field and the gender field
let's apply a special rule
for the first name property where the
user must enter at least two characters
for this field
and not be allowed to enter more than
100 characters into this field
we can use the string length attribute
to enforce this rule
let's apply the same rule for the last
name property
let's declare the email address
attribute against the email field to
ensure that the user enters an email
address that conforms to a valid email
address format
you can of course create your own custom
validation attribute by creating classes
that inherit from the validation
attribute base clause
this functionality is beyond the scope
of this course but it is easy to
implement you can then apply your own
custom validation attributes to the
relevant properties
so you are able to apply whatever
validation rules that are required
to any input field within the syncfusion
data grid
the sync fusion data grid
allows a user
to export the data displayed within the
data grid to an excel spreadsheet you
are able to automatically export the
data displayed within the syncfusion
data grid to an excel spreadsheet or a
pdf document with minimal additional
code so to enable the user to export the
data in the data grid to an excel
spreadsheet let's first add an
appropriate toolbar button to our
datagrids toolbar like this
then within the sf grid element let's
include the allow excel export property
and set its value to true
then we are able to hook into an event
that is fired when the user clicks a
button on the toolbar by setting the on
toolbar click property within the grid
events element to an event handler
method that we'll create in just a bit
the implementation for our event handler
method is really simple
so if the user clicks the excel export
button
run the sync fusion data grids export to
excel async method
and look at that excellent
let's allow pdf export
and let's implement the appropriate code
in our toolbar btn click handler event
handler method
let's of course include a pdf export
button on the datagrits toolbar
great
let's say we wanted to include a button
on the data grids toolbar that when
clicked executes custom functionality
let's say for example we wanted the data
in the grid to be exported to a special
xml format
we can easily achieve this
we can create our own custom buttons on
the datagrids toolbar using the item
model type which resides within the
syncfusion.blazer.navigations namespace
like this
in the interests of time i'm not going
to write such xml custom functionality
but i'll demonstrate how we are able to
include a custom button on the datagrid
toolbar and how custom functionality can
be executed when the relevant custom
button is clicked by the user
great
we are able to create columns that
contain command buttons within our data
grid
say for example we wanted to execute the
edit and delete operations
from buttons that appear at the end of
each row within our grid rather than
through the relevant buttons on the data
grids toolbar
we can include the grid command columns
element within an appropriate grid
column element to achieve this
we can then include the appropriate grid
command column elements within the grid
command columns element
and style them appropriately like this
so now we are able to use these buttons
to edit and save our data
and we can use this button to delete
relevant data
excellent
we are also able to include our own
custom command buttons within the data
grid
like this
we must of course wrap the grid command
column elements within the grid command
columns element like this
excellent
and if we choose to handle our updates
and delete operations using the command
buttons we can remove the relevant
buttons from the toolbar
great
the default mode for our grid is normal
mode
in normal mode when we edit a row of
data in our data grid we edit the
relevant fields
directly within the data grid itself
when we add a new record to our data
grid while in normal mode a blank new
row appears at the top of the grid
and we can input the values for the
relevant fields directly within the data
grid
we are able to edit or add our data
using two other modes
dialog mode and batch mode
let's first discuss dialog mode
using dialog mode when a user edits a
row in the data grid
or adds a row to the data grid a dialog
is presented to the user with the
relevant editable fields
so the user is able to perform the edit
or add operation
using a separate dialog rather than
applying the relevant changes directly
to the data grid so to indicate that we
want the user to add and edit data using
a separate dialog
rather than performing these actions
directly on the grid for this purpose
we must set the mode property of the
grid edit settings element to the edit
mode dot dialog enum value
now when a user adds a record or editor
record a new dialog pops up
and the relevant operation is done using
this dialog
we are able to customize the dialog for
example we can disable certain fields
for add or edit operations like this
we can customize the header for example
we may want a heading on the dialog to
reflect the action that is being
performed
to customize the header for the dialog
we must add the header template element
to the grid edit settings element like
this
then we are able to implement our code
to handle the relevant customization
functionality
great
we are also able to customize the footer
of the dialog and for example change the
captions on the buttons
based on the operation being performed
then we can hook into the relevant
button events and ensure that the
appropriate functionality is executed
like this
the cancel button simply closes the
dialog
the save button executes the relevant
save functionality and then closes the
dialogue
great
you are also able to include the
template element within the grid edit
settings element to customize the fields
and layout of the fields displayed to
the user within the dialogue
please consult the sync fusion
documentation for comprehensive
information on how to do this
batch mode
so let's look at what we are able to
achieve using batch mode
when our data grid is in batch mode we
are able to perform more than one
operation on multiple rows of data
before saving our data
for example a user can add a new record
edit a different existing record and
delete a record before pressing the
update button to save the effects of all
three actions at once
in batch mode the user's add edit and
delete operations can be executed in a
batch all at once
so to run our data grid in batch mode we
simply set the mode property here
to the edit mode dot batch enum value
let's include the update and cancel
buttons within the toolbar of the data
grid once again because in batch mode we
are going to be able to edit multiple
rows so performing the save operation
once a batch of operations have been
performed by using the appropriate
toolbar button seems more appropriate
you can see that once we have edited a
field and the field loses focus that the
background color of the relevant cell is
set to green
so at a glance the user is able to see
which fields in the data grid have been
modified before the user saves the
relevant data
then once the user has finished the
batch edit the user can press the update
button on the toolbar to save all of the
user's changes
however this action at the moment will
only save the changes to the data grid
and will not make the relevant changes
to our database
so to propagate the changes through to
the database
we are able to hook into an event
triggered by the user's action to save a
batch of changes made to the data grid
so to do this within the grid events
element let's set a property named on
batch save to the name of a method that
we are going to write which will handle
the on batch save event
and you can see via intellisense the
method definition or method signature if
you like
of the event handler method that we need
to write to handle the on batch save
event
so let's create this method and let's
appropriately name it on batch update
handler
so through the args argument passed to
the on batch update handler method
we have access to the records that have
been added changed and deleted
the logic for our code simply traverses
these records and executes the
appropriate operations
excellent
and then of course as demonstrated
earlier we are easily able to include
functionality like paging in our
syncfusion data grid like this
if we want to include a maximum of six
rows of data per page
let's adjust our page size to five
we can also easily include grouping
functionality into our data grid by
including this code in our datagrid
component
we can include basic filtering
functionality for each column in our
data grid by including the allow
filtering property within the sf grid
element and setting its value to true
great and we can include more
sophisticated filtering functionality
for each column in our grid by including
the grid filter settings element within
the sf grid element and setting the type
property for example to
syncfusion.blazer
then we are able to filter our data by
either filtering on one column or a
combination of columns in a variety of
useful ways
excellent
so in this part of the course we have
demonstrated how we are able to use the
data grid for providing sophisticated
functionality to the user and we've been
able to integrate the sophisticated
functionality with ease into our sales
management application
with clean and easy to read code
we have been able to customize the data
grid to suit our application's
requirement
please explore the comprehensive
documentation and demo source code
provided by syncfusion on their website
where you'll be able to delve even
deeper into the vast amounts of
functionality that can be leveraged
through the use of the syncfusion
datagrid component
so the developer is able to provide
extremely rich and powerful
functionality with minimal declarative
code through the integration of the
datagrid into an application
please see the code on github for what
the code should look like for our
particular requirement
so in this section of the course
we are going to create a facility where
sales reps can for example
log on to the system when they are on
site with a client and order products
for the relevant client from a product
catalog so for example an outdoor
excellence sales rep regularly visits
clients of outdoor excellence
a client could be a buyer for a retail
outlet that specializes in selling
outdoor and sports products
the sales rep presents a product catalog
to the client and the client is able to
instruct the sales rep on which products
the client wishes to purchase
from the product catalog
the sales rep can then using the sales
management app simply check the check
boxes
next to the products that the client
wishes to order through the app and
press a button to order the checked
products
details of the order are then processed
by the system and data is captured
regarding for example
the order price products
date of the order the employee id of the
sales rep responsible for the order the
client id of the client that instructs
the sales rep to make the particular
order the location of the retail outlet
etc
a little bit later in the course
we are going to use syncfusion charts to
display useful metrics gleaned from the
order data that is captured when a
client makes an order or multiple orders
through the sales management application
so in this section of the course
basically we are going to create
functionality for displaying a product
catalog and also facilitate a basic
ordering system so that a sales rep can
create an order directly from the
product catalog for the relevant client
so let's first create the display
product catalog functionality
so let's first create a razor component
named product catalog
let's use the at page directive to set
up the appropriate routing information
for the product catalog razer component
let's include a link to our new razor
component within the nav menu razer file
great
before we write the front-end code to
display the products to the user let's
create a products database table and a
product categories database table using
ef core code first migrations
as we have already discussed the
products table has a many-to-one
relationship with the product categories
table
for example the product category named
camping can contain different types of
tent products as well as different types
of air mattresses
the mountain bikes product category can
contain many types of mountain bikes so
the relationship is one product category
too many products or conversely many
products to one product category
okay so let's create the product entity
within the entities folder
great
let's create the product category entity
great
let's add the appropriate db set
properties to our sales management db
context class
great
let's create a migration and name it add
product tables
let's run our migration by typing in the
update database command and pressing the
enter key
excellent
so let's seed our product categories
table and products table with data
i've already prepared product related
data off-screen so that we can see that
database with appropriate product
category data and appropriate product
data
please copy the relevant product seed
data code from the github web page at
this location a link to this webpage has
been included below in the description
so let's open the seed data class from
within the data folder
and let's add a static method named add
product data
then let's copy the relevant code from
the relevant github web page
and paste it into our new add product
data static method
then we can call the add product data
method
from within the on model creating method
of our sales management db context class
let's add a migration named seed product
data
great
let's update the database by running the
update dash database command
excellent
so you can see we have an image path
for each product row stored within the
products database table
i've prepared images for each of the
products off screen
please download these images from this
location on github
a link to the location is available
below in the description of this video
then let's create a folder within the
www root slash images folder named
products
and paste the images that we have just
downloaded from github within this
products folder
great
so we can now create the database
related functionality to retrieve the
data related to our products
before we create a service for this
purpose let's create a product model
class
this class will serve as the type for
each product object displayed on the ui
in our product catalog razer component
let's create an interface within the
contracts folder named i product service
let's create a definition for a method
that will be responsible for retrieving
product data from our database
let's create a class named product
service
where we'll implement the logic for the
method definitions defined within the i
product service interface
let's create a constructor that accepts
an argument of type sales management db
context
an object of type sales management db
context will be injected into this
constructor at runtime
let's generate a field to reference the
relevant sales management db context
object
so before we implement the logic for our
get products method let's create an
appropriate convert extension method
for the purpose of transforming a
collection of product objects to a
collection of product model objects
great
we can pass in the sales management db
context object
to our extension method
so that we can join to the product
category entity in the relevant link
query by doing this we are able to
include the product category name in our
list of product model data that will be
returned to the calling code
oops we have a little typo to fix here
so let's go to the product model class
and fix the issue
not decryption but rather description
then the code for the get products
method is simply this
great we want to use the syncfusion list
view component
to display our product data on the user
interface
to do this we first need to install the
dot
syncfusion.blazer.list
new get package
i see during the development of this
application a new version of the
syncfusion components has been released
we have currently been using version
20.1.0.58
of the syncfusion components
so to be consistent let's install
version 20.1.0.58
of the
syncfusion.blazer.lists nuget package we
can always update our installation of
our syncfusion components to the latest
version at a later time
great
let's include a using directive that
references the syncfusion.blaser.lists
namespace at the top of our code
in this razor component our code is
going to refer to types within the sales
management app.entitiesnamespace
the
salesmanagementapp.services.contracts
namespace and the sales management app
dot services namespace
so let's cut the relevant directive code
from the employee management razer
component and paste this code within the
underscore imports.razer file this means
that these directives will now be
applicable to all of our razor
components
let's write code so that a product
service object is injected into our
product catalog razor component at run
time
let's create a parent div tag that
contains a bootstrap class so that this
div represents a row within the
bootstrap grid system
let's create a div element that contains
a bootstrap class to indicate that the
content within this div
should take up all 12 columns of the
bootstrap grid
within this div let's create declarative
code to include the sf list view
component appropriately within our razer
component
let's write code to override blaze's
uninitialized async lifecycle event
handler method
let's create a variable that will
reference the data that we'll use as a
data source for our syncfusion list view
component this data source will of
course contain items of type product
model to store the product data
retrieved from our database
then we can use our product service
functionality
to retrieve our products data from the
database and assign this returned value
to the private variable named product
data that we will wire up as the data
source for our syncfusion list view
component
so let's appropriately set the data
source property of the sf list view
element to the product data variable
actually let's change our products data
variable
into a property and capitalize the p in
product data
great
let's not forget to register our product
service type for dependency injection
great
let's include a list view field settings
element within our sf list view element
like this
let's set the t value property within
the list view field settings element to
product model
let's set the id property to id and the
text property to name
so here we are telling the sync fusion
list view component as it were
which property denotes the value of a
list view item and which property of the
list view item which remembers of type
product model should be displayed on the
ui
and there it is our products are
displayed neatly within our list view
component
so of course we are able to customize
our sync fusion list view component so
that it suits our particular requirement
firstly let's say we want our products
displayed
so that they are grouped by product
category
we are able to do this by setting the
grouped by property in the list view
field settings element to the property
of the product model type by which we
want our list of products grouped so we
want to group our products by product
category
so we can achieve this by grouping by
the category name property of the
product model type like this
great
we are able to customize the look of the
grouped field
through the use of the list view
templates component
so let's include
the list view templates element within
the sf list view element
let's set the t value property to the
type of objects stored
in the data source that we have wired up
to the syncfusion list view component
then we can include code to specifically
target the field by which we are
grouping the data
to do this
we can include the group template
element within the list view templates
element
then we can use the context object to
reference a particular list item
and of course each list item is of type
product model
we are able to include basic html like
this to style the category name property
of the product model type
and that looks pretty good
we can include the template element
within the listview templates element to
style the list items
within the template element we can use
html and css
to style the fields we want to display
to the user
for each list item in the list view
the sync fusion list view component
makes each product model list item
available to us in code through the
context object
so we are able to include which fields
from the product model type we want to
display in our template using the
context object
notice that we are using certain sync
fusion css classes to style the list
view items
so before we continue let's use the
tostring
and net globalization functionality to
force the currency to be displayed as u
s dollars like this
let's set the css class property
of the sf list view grid component to
sync fusion's e-list dash template css
class
for more detail on the css structure
in the blazer list view component please
check out syncfusion's documentation
regarding this topic at this location
a link to this webpage has been included
in the description of this video
let's also include a class named list
view dash template
we can customize the style for our list
view using appropriate css code
let's run the code
and i think that looks pretty good
so i want to include a checkbox next to
every list item so that the user can
easily select the products
from the product catalog before placing
an order
to include this functionality
all we need to do is add the show
checkbox property within the sf list
view element
and set its value to true
excellent
with each order made on behalf of a
client by a sales rep we also need to
include relevant client information
so we want to include a combo box that
is populated with a list of clients
the sales rep can then choose the client
on whose behalf an order is created from
the combo box before placing the
relevant order
so firstly let's create a c-sharp class
named client within the entities folder
like this to represent the client entity
great
let's also create a c-sharp class named
retail outlet
and include these properties within the
retail outlet class this c-sharp class
represents the retail outlet entity
the client entity has a one-to-one
relationship with the retail outlet
entity
a client works for a retail outlet
and serves as the point of contact for
an outdoor excellence sales rep
let's include the relevant dbset
properties so that ef core will include
code within our next migration to create
the corresponding database tables within
our database
let's generate the migration code
and let's update the database
great
let's seed our clients and our retail
outlets tables with data
please copy the relevant code for
seeding these tables from the github web
page found at this location
a link to this page has been included in
the description of this video so within
the seed data class let's create a
static method named add clients
let's paste the appropriate code that we
have copied from the relevant github web
page into the add clients method
ok so to be consistent let's rename our
add clients method to add client data
let's then call the add client data
method from within the on model creating
method within the sales management db
context class
let's create a migration named seed
client data
great
let's update the database with our
client data by typing in the update
database command and then pressing the
enter key
excellent
before we create a service responsible
for our client functionality let's
create a c-sharp class named client
model within the models folder
great
let's create an interface named i client
service
let's create a definition for a method
that will be responsible for retrieving
client data from the database
let's implement the logic for the get
clients method within a new class named
client service
before we do this
let's create an overload for the convert
extension method that converts a
collection of client objects to a
collection of client model objects
we want to join our client entity to the
retail outlet entity within our convert
extension method
so we must also pass in the sales
management db context object
within our link query let's join the
clients collection to the retail outlets
collection so that we can include
location related information within the
returned list
then our code logic for our get clients
method is very simple
great
let's go to our product catalog razor
component
let's write code to include a syncfusion
combo box within the product catalog
razer component
let's create a property that will
reference the data source that we are
going to wire up to the combo box
let's write code to retrieve the client
data from our database within our
override method of the uninitialized
async laser lifecycle event handler
method
in order to access an object
of type i client service
we must write code
to inject an object of type i client
service
into our razor component at runtime
we must of course remember to register
our client service type for dependency
injection within the program.cs class
like this
then let's set the data source property
within the sf combobox element to the
client data property
let's set the t value property to end
and the t item property to client model
the t value property setting tells the
syncfusion combobox component as it were
what data type is used for the value of
each item included within the combo box
the t item property setting tells the
syncfusion combo box as it were the type
of each item that is included within the
combo box
then we can use the at bind dash value
attribute to bind the value of the
selected combobox list item to a
property that we are going to create
so let's create a property for this
purpose named client id
and initialize its value to one
we must include an element named combo
box field settings within the sf
combobox element and then we can define
which property of the client model type
we wish to display to the user by
appropriately setting the text property
we can also declare which property
denotes the value of the items contained
within the combo box by setting the
value property to an appropriate
property in the client model type
let's run the code
great
and the user is able to type in text
that alludes to a particular retail
outlet into the combo box
and the sync fusion combo box will
navigate to a matching item in the list
great
let's appropriately style our layout and
our combo box
great
let's create a c-sharp class within the
entities folder named order
great let's create a c-sharp class
within the entities folder named order
item
great
the order entity has a one-to-many
relationship with the order item entity
one order can contain one or many order
items
let's add the necessary dbcontext
properties so that the order entity and
the order item entity
are used for creating the corresponding
database tables in our database
let's create an appropriate migration
and let's update the database
by running the update dash database
command
great
we don't need to see the data for these
tables because we are going to generate
the relevant order data through our
application
let's create a class named order model
within the models folder
let's create an interface named i order
service within the contracts folder
let's create a definition for a method
that will be responsible for creating
order data within our system
let's create a c-sharp class named order
service and implement the code logic for
the create order method
so firstly we need to add an order to
the system so let's create an order
object and get its property values
from the order model object passed into
this method as an argument
for now we are hard coding the employee
id for our orders to nine
which is the id
of the employee named benjamin lucas
who is a sales rep
one of the last things we are going to
do in this course is integrate microsoft
identity authentication and login
functionality into our application
as part of the login functionality we'll
be able to retrieve the id of the
logged-on employee
so we'll be able to get the appropriate
employee id field at this point based on
the logged on users details
for now while we test our functionality
let's simply hard code the employee id
field where necessary
then we can create code to add the order
to the system like this
and the add async method returns the
order entity saved to the system
and this is how we are able to reference
the id of the order that has just been
added to the database
the order entity has a one-to-many
relationship with the order item entity
the order item entity has an order id
property which is a foreign key from the
order entity
so we must insert the order entity into
the database
and reference the id of the newly added
order entity that has just been added to
the database
this must be done
before we add the orders relevant order
items to the database each order item
must reference
the order's id
before we add the relevant order items
to the database each order item must
contain an order id value pertaining to
an order that has been added to the
database
let's create a private method
that returns the order item collection
where each order item contains the
relevant order id value
then we can use the add range method to
add the relevant order items to the
database
we also need to sum up the price of all
the order items pertaining to the
relevant order
and sum up the quantity of items that
were included for the order like this
great
so these summing operations are done
before the order is added to the
database
and subsequently the order items are
added to the database
so let's go to the product catalog.razer
file and write code so that an object of
type i order service is passed into the
product catalog razer component at
runtime
let's register the i order service type
for dependency injection
let's include a button that a user can
click to create an order in the system
based on the product items that have
been checked in the list view
let's wire up an event handler method
that we'll create in a bit
for the purpose of handling the relevant
button click event
in this case the logic for the event
handler method will entail collating a
selected list of products i.e the
products that have been checked in our
list view
and passing the list of products which
denotes the order items in the client's
order
to the relevant order service
functionality
so let's create the create order event
handler method
so in order to get the selected product
items from the list of products
we need to be able to reference the sf
list view component in code
so we can use the at ref attribute for
this purpose
when the create order button is clicked
by the user
our code for creating the order is fired
so let's write the code
for the relevant buttonclickeventhandler
method
that carries out the task of creating an
order in the system
we are able to use a variable of the
generic type selected items that is
strongly typed with our product model
type to reference the objects of type
product model that pertain to the items
in the list view that the user checks
which means these products will become
part of an order when the user clicks
the create order button
we can use our sf products lv object
that is referenced within the sf list
view element to get the checked list
items by calling the get checked items
async method on the sf products lv
object
each of the checked product items will
become the basis for an order item we
can use the order model type to create
an object that contains relevant order
information
and the relevant order item collection
note that each checked product is the
basis for an order item
then we can pass this data as an
argument to the create order method like
this
let's test the code
great but the order id
in the order items table is zero for our
order so it doesn't correctly
relate
to the order that we created which is
incorrect
let's investigate what went wrong here
oh i can see what the problem is
we must include a line of code to save
our changes
when we add an order to the system
so this is ef core functionality whereby
the save changes async method must be
called
after an entity is added to the database
table
so
we must call the ef cause save changes
async method like this after the code
that adds the relevant entity to the
database is executed
so i'm going to delete the incorrect
data that we have just inserted into the
orders table and the order items table
using the sql truncate table statement
within sql server management studio
by using the truncate table statement
instead of simply deleting the data the
primary key columns will be initialized
back to zero
so let's try again
excellent
we now have the correct order id value
being inserted into the order items
table
however the date for the order dates
time column is not correct
so let's truncate the orders and the
order items table again
let's go to our order service class
and we can easily correct this issue by
setting the order date time property
here to date time dot now which denotes
the current date and time
so that's great we are able to create
our order
but currently the user has no way of
knowing if the user's order has been
successful
so we need a way to notify the user as
to whether the user's order has been
successful or unsuccessful
let's use syncfusion's toast component
for this purpose
so once a user places an order we want a
message to pop up like toast
informing the user whether the user's
order has been successful or
unsuccessful
so to install syncfusion's toast
component let's right-click the
dependencies node in visual studio's
solution explorer window
and select manage new get packages in
order to invoke the new get package
manager window
let's go to the browse tab and search
for toast
the syncfusion.blazer.notifications
new get package appears in our list
and this is the package we want to
install
so let's install version 20.1.0.58
there is a later version
but we can always update our packages to
a later version at a later stage let's
keep our package versions consistent and
install version 20.1.0.58
let's add a using directive that
references the
syncfusion.blazer.notifications
namespace to our product catalog razer
file
so in the syncfusion demo documentation
at this location
i've found the functionality that i want
to incorporate into our application
so i'm simply going to copy the code
from this syncfusion documentation
and integrate it into our product
catalog razer component
let's copy the code for the sf toast
component from the syncfusion demo code
here
and paste it into our code here
let's include this code that has a
variable that we'll use to reference our
sf toast component
and a variable used for positioning our
toast object on the screen
let's include the code here where a list
is created containing various toast
types for example for success and error
scenarios
let's grab all of this code
used for the styling of our toast
and appropriately paste it into our
product catalog razer file
then we can create the code for showing
our toast within our create order method
like this
so if our code reaches this line here it
means the order has been processed
successfully so let's write codes to pop
up the toast that represents success
note that off screen i have changed the
success message to a message more
appropriate for our requirement
so this message now reads your order has
been created successfully
let's test the code
excellent
let's include the code that represents
that our order has failed
within the catch section of our try
catch block
to test this error scenario
let's include a line of code
that forces an exception to occur
and we are now handling the exception
with our toast
so we don't want to throw the exception
here
so let's comment out this line of code
here
let's test the code
excellent
let's remove the line of code that we
have included to force an exception to
occur
the last piece of functionality i'd like
to add for our product catalog razer
component
is so that the user is able to filter
the products in the catalog
while typing in text within a text box
above the list view component
so let's include a syncfusion text box
in a row just below our syncfusion combo
box here in our code like this
let's bring in the namespace of where
the syncfusion text box resides
the
syncfusion.blazer.inputs namespace
to filter our list view by product name
as the user types text within our sync
fusion text box
we can use the input property in the sf
text box element and wire it up to an
event handler method that we'll create
in just a bit
let's first create a variable named
product collection filter
that will be used to filter our product
list
let's write code to assign the list of
products
stored within the data source of our
sync fusion list view component to the
product collection filter variable
within the uninitialized async method
and the code for our on input event
handler method should look like this
our code is filtering the product
collection filter list
every time a user enters a character
into the sync fusion text box
then we are assigning the result of the
filtering operation to the data source
of the syncfusion list view component
which is the list stored in the product
data property
and that's great
all works as expected
but there are certain layout and styling
concerns that need attention
so let's address these issues
just a reminder the full code is
available on github a link to the
relevant repository is available below
in the description of this video
and that looks great
and let's press f12 while using our
chrome browsers
to see how this looks on different
screen sizes
great our front end code is fully
responsive
excellent
so at this stage in the course
we have created functionality where
sales reps can place orders on behalf of
their clients
this order data that is being captured
can be very useful for sales reps team
leaders
and the sales manager for analytical
purposes for example from the captured
data a sales rep can see how well the
sales rep is performing and see which
products are generating the most sales
a team leader can see how well each of
the team leaders team members are doing
relative to one another and see how well
the team leaders team is doing overall
the sales manager can see how well the
sales department is doing overall
the sales data can be aggregated by
location and over a period of time
as developers the challenge is to
present the relevant analytical data in
a human readable way to the user
so the user can derive useful knowledge
when analyzing the relevant data
sync fusion has created excellent chart
components that address the issue of
presenting analytical data in an
aesthetically pleasing and human
readable way
it's like the old adage says a picture
speaks a thousand words
these charts are highly sophisticated
and easy to implement they are easy to
integrate into our code
so in the first part of this section of
the course we are going to create a
razor component that displays three
basic charts using appropriate
syncfusion chart components
this is so that we first gain a basic
understanding of how a developer can
harness the power of the syncfusion
charts in a razer component
we'll then progress further and create a
dashboard for each type of employee in
the sales department each dashboard will
be implemented as a razer component
we'll create a dashboard for the sales
reps that presents three sync fusion
charts with data that is relevant to
sales reps we'll create a dashboard for
team leaders that presents three charts
with data that is relevant to the team
leaders and lastly we'll create a
dashboard for the sales manager that
presents three charts with data that is
relevant to the sales manager
we'll implement code for three different
types of popular charts bar charts donut
charts and line charts
before we build the dashboards let's
create a temporary razer component so
that we can gain a basic understanding
of how to use the relevant syncfusion
charts in this razor component we'll
implement the code for three types of
charts a bar chart a donut chart and a
line chart
so let's create a razor component named
charts
let's create an appropriate link within
the nav menu razer component
before we implement code for our charts
it would be a good idea to consolidate
our order reports data into one database
table
so we are going to create a denormalized
table in our database to store our
analytical data i.e the data we are
going to wire up to our charts let's see
what wikipedia says about
denormalization
denormalization is a strategy used on a
previously normalized database to
increase performance
in computing denormalization is the
process of trying to improve the read
performance of a database at the expense
of losing some right performance
so for the transactional database tables
where the tables are written too
frequently our database designed for
these tables is based on the strategy of
normalization which we briefly discussed
earlier
so basically by creating a denormalized
table for storing the analytical data we
are eliminating the need for creating a
lot of joins when implementing our link
queries for the purpose of retrieving
the relevant analytical data from the
database to be displayed within our
charts
by querying a denormalized table we
eliminate the need for these joins and
our link queries will be a lot simpler
our code will be easier to read and the
process of retrieving the relevant data
will be a lot more efficient
the technique of denormalization is
often used in olap online analytical
processing applications the details of
olap are beyond the scope of this course
very briefly
in olap applications data can be
organized into data cubes which makes
the retrieval of aggregated data derived
from multi-dimensional criteria
efficient
the data does not need to be retrieved
from the transactional database tables
that have been designed using
normalization so basically this
eliminates the need for including joins
within the queries for retrieving the
relevant analytical data from the
database
so our application is not an olap
application but some of the principles
that are used in the creation of an olap
application are relevant to how we are
going to implement our analytical
functionality in our application
we are essentially going to organize the
data that will be displayed on our
charts into appropriate shapes using
appropriate link queries
that will be used for querying our
denormalized table i.e the sales order
report database table the relevant
results of the link queries will then be
wired up to the relevant syncfusion
chart components
if this is unclear to you at the moment
don't worry this will become clearer as
we create the relevant code
so
say for example we want to create a
report for total sales quantity broken
down by state or location
the aggregated data quantity of sales is
derived summed up by the location
dimension
so within our data we have the concept
of dimensions and measures
the dimension here is the location and
the measure is the quantity of sales
which is aggregated summed up by
location
so if we add another dimension
this will of course effect the
aggregated data for example a period of
time could be our other dimension for
example we could further aggregate the
data by the months of the current year
displaying such data in a chronological
order by months
shows progress or lack of progress in
terms of sales performance over a period
of time per location
so the aggregated data is the quantity
of sales the measure and the dimensions
of the data are the period by month and
the location by state
so let's create the code for generating
our denormalized database table
let's create a class within the entities
folder named sales order report
this model is going to have quite a few
properties so just a reminder you can
copy the relevant code from github if
you'd prefer rather than follow along
with me as i create the properties for
this class
and you can see that we are including
fields from the relevant transactional
database tables each row in the table we
are about to create will denote an order
item
in each row in this table
in addition to the order item
information we are also including for
example the relevant client information
i.e the client responsible for the order
the employee information i.e the sales
rep responsible for creating the order
in the system the order date time the
location where the order was initiated
etc
any information that we may wish to
include in our analytical data is being
included in this table the table is
denormalized a lot of the data is going
to be redundant
in other words the data is repeated in
each of the rows whereas in a normalized
structure the normalization process
serves to eliminate data redundancy and
increase data integrity
great so we have created our class that
represents the sales order report entity
let's create the appropriate db set
property within the sales management
dbcontext class
let's generate a migration
and let's update the database
the next step is to appropriately
include code to add relevant order
information to our sales order reports
table when an order is created
note that in an olap application
relevant analytical data wouldn't
necessarily be captured in the database
in real time i.e as the order is created
in an olap application the data may be
collated from for example the relevant
transaction databases
and transferred over to a separate
database in a separate process that runs
for example once a day in the early
hours of the morning the data for
analytical purposes could for example be
stored in a data warehouse for the sake
of simplicity in our example we are
simply going to capture the data into
our sales order reports table at the
time at which the order is processed
let's create a private method for
inserting the relevant data into the
sales order reports table
in the interests of time i'm going to
paste the relevant code that i've
prepared offline into our private method
please feel free to copy the code for
this method from the relevant github web
page
then we can call our update sales order
reports private method after the order
data has been inserted into the relevant
transactional database tables i.e the
orders table and the order items table
so we could run this in an ef core
transaction
so all three processes i.e inserting
data into the orders table the order
items table and the sales order reports
table are executed in one process i.e if
one process fails then all processes
fail
i won't implement this code as a
transaction at this point but this is
something that can easily be done here
using ef core functionality
i have however included the relevant
transaction code in the version of the
code that resides in the github
repository that stores the code for this
application please see a link to this
repository below in the description
so let's run the code to see if our
order data is being captured in our
sales order reports table
excellent
before we create the code for our charts
in our razor component let's remove the
data from the sales order reports table
the order items table and the orders
table
so let's create report related models
that will serve as the types
for the objects that store the data for
specific reports
let's first create a folder within the
models folder named report models
within the report models folder let's
create a class named grouped field price
model this model represents the type for
an object that stores aggregated price
data for a particular grouped field that
will be specified in the relevant link
queries used for querying and shaping
the returned analytical data
let's create an interface named i sales
order report service
let's create a method definition for a
method named get employee price per
month that is responsible for returning
analytical data for a particular sales
rep and show the employees gross sales
broken down by month for the current
year
the first chart we are going to create
will be a bar chart that displays the
gross sales value per month for the
logged on employee
the sales rep
we are only going to create the relevant
login functionality toward the end of
this course so for now we are going to
hard code the relevant employee id to
nine which is the id for the sales rep
named benjamin lucas in our employees
database table
let's implement the code logic for our i
sales order reports service interface
in a class named sales order report
service
so in the get employee price per month
method let's create a link query that
returns the gross sales per month for
benjamin lucas
note that i haven't specified the year
in this query
we are going to assume that the data in
our database only applies to the current
year
note that i have included the relevant
filter code in the where clause in the
version of the code that resides in the
relevant github repository ie to filter
the relevant data by the current year
great
and that is our query
we are ready to create the code for our
first chart which will be a bar chart so
let's go to our charts razer component
let's first install the relevant nuget
package so in order to use the
syncfusion charts we must install the
syncfusion.blazer.charts nuget package
let's choose version 20.1.0.58
to keep consistent with the versions of
the other syncfusion components we can
always update our components
to the latest version at a later stage
let's include an appropriate using
directive at the top of our code to
reference the
syncfusion.blazer.charts namespace
let's create a div container element
where our sync fusion chart will reside
let's override the uninitialized async
blazer lifecycle event handler method
let's create a list property that stores
objects of type grouped field price
model
the grouped field price model type
resides in the sales management
app.models.report models namespace
many of the types that we'll create
within the sales management app dot
models dot report models namespace will
be used across other razor components so
let's create an appropriate using
directive that references the sales
management app dot models dot report
models namespace within the underscore
imports.razer file
let's write code so that an object of
type i sales order report service is
injected into our razor component at
runtime
let's appropriately call the get
employee price per month data method on
the sales order report service object
and assign the returned data to the
appropriate property let's register the
i sales order report service type for
dependency injection within the
program.cs class
let's create the code for our first
syncfusion chart
let's give the title property of the sf
chart component a value of sales gross
forward slash month let's include the
chart primary x axis element within the
sf chart element
let's set its value type property to
syncfusion.laser.charts.valuetype.category
let's include the chart series
collection element within the sf chart
element
let's include a chart series element
within the chart series collection
element
we are about to set the data source
property for the chart series element
but before we proceed with this let's
rename the property that stores the data
source data to a more appropriate name
right
let's set the data source property of
the chart series element to our grouped
field price data property
let's set the xname property to the
grouped key field property name of the
group fieldpricemodel type
let's set the yname property to the
price property name of the grouped field
price model type
lastly let's set the type of our chart
to bar chart
we can do this by setting the relevant
type property like this
let's run our code
and that is what i would expect seeing
as we don't yet have any data in the
sales order report database table
so we are now able to insert data into
the sales order reports database table
through our application so let's do that
let's click the products nav menu link
and let's use our ordering facility to
place an order
great
and let's now invoke the charts razor
component
and the relevant data is now displayed
on our bar chart
we don't have a lot of data yet so our
chart is not displaying a lot of
information
let's create a few more orders to
generate more report related data in our
database
to make our data more interesting let's
go into sql server management studio and
modify our order data so that our data
reflects that some of the orders were
made in different months of the current
year
great and our bar chart looks a lot more
interesting now
great so we have created our first chart
which is a bar chart
let's create a donut chart i love these
charts but in particular i love doughnut
charts
let's first create a model in our report
models folder
let's name this model grouped field qty
model
let's create a new method definition
within our i sales order report service
interface named get qty per product
category that will be responsible for
returning data reflecting the quantity
sold by an employee for each product
category
let's implement the code logic for the
get qt wiper product category method
as you can see we are grouping the data
by product category here in our link
query
we should include a where clause that
filters the query by the employee id of
9 benjamin lucas's id
but these sort of specifics don't matter
at the moment because everything
currently has been done by benjamin
lucas
as we have hard-coded this id for the
order capture functionality
so we are assuming benjamin lucas has
logged onto the system and is viewing
data pertaining to his sales
let's go to our charts.razer file
let's create a property that will be the
data source for our donut chart
let's use our sales order service object
to return the data for our donut chart
from the database to our razor component
so let's create the code for our donut
chart
so in order to do this let's include
syncfusion's sf accumulation chart
element in our code like this
as you can see the code is very
straightforward we include the
appropriate elements declaratively in
our code
with the appropriate settings regarding
how we want our donut chart to look
let's set the data source property to
our grouped field qty data property
we can then declaratively set the
dimension for our analytical data
we must set the xname property of the
accumulation chart series element to the
grouped field key property of our
grouped field qty model type
we must set the y name property to the
qty property
we are able to customize our chart
through various settings
please view the comprehensive
documentation provided by syncfusion for
more detail on the chart components we
are just scraping this surface here you
are able to customize your charts in
various ways the functionality in the
sync fusion charts is very sophisticated
and as you can see syncfusion has made
it very easy for developers to leverage
the sophistication of the charts through
the implementation of simple declarative
code
let's run the code and see what our
donut chart looks like
excellent and we can at a glance see how
many products
benjamin lucas has sold for each product
category great
let's create another type of chart a
line chart
so let's first create the functionality
to retrieve the data for our line chart
let's create a definition for a method
named get qty per month data
which will be responsible for retrieving
data representing the quantity of
products ordered through benjamin lucas
and the data is broken down by months of
the current year
we can reuse our grouped field qty model
type for the objects in the list
returned by this method
let's implement the logic for our new
method
so the code structure for our new method
is very similar to the code structure
for the get employee price per month
method so let's start by copying the
code in the get employee price per month
method and pasting it into our new
method
so we are grouping the data by month
and summing up the quantity of sales
made for each month
this analytical data applies to the
sales rep benjamin lucas so we are
filtering the data by his employee id of
nine
let's go to the charts razor component
and wire up the line chart with the data
retrieved using the sales order service
object
let's rename the data source for our
donut chart to a name that is more
descriptive
and let's name the property that will
store the data for the line charts data
source
qty per month data
let's also change the name of the
property that stores the data
for the data source of the bar chart to
a name that is more descriptive
okay so let's write the code that
retrieves the data for the line chart
and assign it to our new property qty
per month data
so the code for our line chart is very
similar to the code for our bar chart
the first chart we created note however
that we are setting the type property in
the chart series element to chart series
type dot line
to make our data more interesting let's
place a few more orders
let's go into sql server management
studio and alter the months of the order
date time field
for some of our captured data
so we have a better spread of our data
as it were across more months
let's look at our charts
and that data looks a lot more
interesting let's look at our line chart
excellent our line chart looks great
you can see the quantity of sales made
by benjamin lucas broken down by the
months of the current year excellent
so these charts look great but our
layout for the charts could use some
attention
let's build our first dashboard for the
sales reps where these charts will be
presented in a great looking layout
appropriate for a dashboard we are going
to use syncfusion's sf dashboard layout
component to implement the layouts for
our dashboards
let's create a razor component named sr
dashboard the sr stands for sales rep
let's create an appropriate route
directive at the top of the razor file
using the at page directive
let's include an appropriate link within
the nav menu razer component
if we navigate to this syncfusion web
page
that can be found at this location a
link to this location has been included
below in the description
we have the source code for a layout
that would be appropriate for our
requirement
so if we click the source tab here
let's copy this code
and paste it into our sr dashboard razer
file
we don't have a sample base component
class
and we don't need this inherits sample
base component line of code here so
let's remove it
for our requirement we don't need the
using theme helper line of code either
so let's remove it
and you can see that we need to install
syncfusion's sf dashboard layout
component
so let's invoke the new get package
manager window from within visual studio
let's search for
syncfusion.blazer.layouts
and this is the package that we want to
install let's install version 20.1.0.58
let's run the code
great
so these are obviously not our charts
but are the ones that are provided in
the syncfusion demo documentation so the
next step is to replace the charts
currently displayed within the sr
dashboard razer component with our
charts
so let's appropriately copy the chart
related code from our charts razer
component
over to the sr dashboard razer component
let's first override the uninitialized
async method and copy and paste the code
for retrieving the relevant data from
our database ie of relevance to the
sales reps analytical data
right so let's appropriately replace
the code for the charts with our charts
code
let's start with the bar chart
okay so we have a few chart references
in the sample code here
let's include a reference to chart 1
within our bar chart component to fix
this issue
great
let's modify the heading in our layout
pertaining to the bar chart to something
more appropriate
let's copy and appropriately paste the
code for the donut chart into our sr
dashboard razor file
great
and lastly the line chart
let's include a reference within our
line chart to chart two
as the sample code that we have copied
from the syncfusion demo documentation
uses a reference to chart 2 in code
excellent
if you have missed a step during this
section of the course
and something isn't working as expected
please refer to the code in the relevant
github repository
and look at how easy it has been to
generate a sophisticated dashboard using
the appropriate sync fusion components
and we can now watch our charts change
appropriately as we place more orders
through the system
excellent
and let's remove the data related code
that is not relevant to our
functionality that we copied from the
syncfusion documentation
we are now of course using the data from
our database for our charts
we have effectively created the
dashboard functionality for our sales
reps and we can now delete the
chartsrazer component from our project
great
so we have removed the chart.razer
component
note that offline i have changed the
employee management link label to admin
so we have just created a dashboard for
our sales reps let's create a dashboard
for team leaders
all of our dashboards will have the same
layout but of course the charts will be
different depending on whether the
logged on user is a sales rep team
leader or sales manager
so each employee will only see one
dashboard when the employee logs on to
the system
when a sales rep logs onto the system
the sales rep will see a link presented
within the main menu of the sales
management application
that points to the sr dashboard
component when a team leader logs on to
the system they'll see one dashboard
link in the main menu but when their
dashboard link is clicked the tl
dashboard razer component will be
invoked
we are going to create the code for the
tl dashboard raiser components in this
section of the course
we'll then create the sm dashboard which
will only be made available to the sales
manager
so let's first create the data retrieval
functionality for the reports relevant
to team leaders
let's open the i sales order reports
interface and create a definition for a
method named get gross sales per team
member data which will be responsible
for returning data containing the gross
sales value for each team member
the data retrieved by the relevant
method will be displayed on a bar chart
let's implement the code logic for this
method definition
so i'm just going to move this method to
the bottom here
so as to separate the team leader
related data retrieval functionality
from the sales rep data retrieval
functionality
so the reports pertaining to team
leaders will relate to data related to
their team members so let's firstly
create a private method that returns a
collection of employee ids pertaining to
each team member that is a member of the
logged on team leaders team
let's name our method get team member
ids
and this link query simply returns a
list of relevant employee ids to the
calling code
so let's call our get team member ids
method from within our get gross sales
per team member data method
then we can filter the data so that the
data is only relevant to the logged on
team leaders team members in the where
clause of our link query for now we are
hard-coding the team leader's id to 3
which pertains to the employee henry
andrews so for now data will only
pertain to the team members that belong
to henry's team
note that benjamin lucas is part of
henry's team so when we create orders
under benjamin lucas
henry andrews will as it were be able to
see the relevant changes to his
analytical data
let's group the team members by their
first names
i know that this is not ideal because
you may have special cases where two or
more team members have the same first
name
for the sake of the example we are going
to assume that team members have unique
first names
let's go back to our i sales order
reports interface and create a
definition for a method named get qty
per team member data responsible for
returning the quantity of sales for each
team member the data relevant to this
method will be displayed on a donut
chart
let's implement the code logic for this
method
in the interests of clarity i'm going to
copy the code for our new method just
below the other team leader related
method
the code for this method is similar in
structure to the previous method we
wrote so let's copy the code from the
previous method that we wrote related to
team leader analytical data and paste it
into our new method
and then let's change the bits that are
different
the aggregated data in this case is
based on the sales quantity rather than
gross sales value the summed up quantity
value is of type integer
and not decimal
so we can remove the code here where we
are rounding off the relevant value to
two decimal places
lastly let's create a definition for a
method named get team qty per month data
this method will be responsible for
retrieving the quantity of sales
pertaining to the team itself overall
and the data will be broken down by the
months of the current year
the data for this will be displayed on a
line chart
let's implement the logic for the get
team qty per month data method
let's create a razor component named tl
dashboard
we are going to use the same layout for
all three of our dashboard razer
components
so let's start by copying the relevant
code from the sr dashboard component and
pasting it into our tl dashboard razor
component like this
then let's change the code so that the
data for the team leader related reports
data is retrieved using the sales order
report service object
the first two charts the bar chart and
the donut chart are very similar to the
first two charts that we created in the
sr dashboard razor component so let's
adapt the existing code for these charts
for the data pertaining to a dashboard
appropriate for team leaders like this
for now let's focus on the two charts
and we'll implement the code for the
line chart the third chart in a bit
so before we run the code
so as to look at the bar chart in the
donut chart for team leaders
let's delete the line chart we'll deal
with the line chart appropriately in a
bit
right let's run the code
the last chart had a at ref attribute
pointing to chart two so let's remove
the reference to chart two from our code
for now
let's run the
code great the charts are displaying
data for only one sales rep at the
moment because the data is reflecting
the fact that only benjamin lucas has
created orders in the system for the
team leader henry andrews
let's modify the data a bit within sql
server management studio to reflect that
other members of the team
led by henry andrews have also created
orders in the system
so to do this let's go to sql server
management studio and modify the data in
the sales order reports database table
accordingly
if we look at the employees we can see
that olivia mills
benjamin lucas sarah henderson and noah
robinson are members of the team led by
henry andrews
the report's two empire d field contains
the value of three for these employees
which is the id value pertaining to the
employee record for henry andrews
so let's open the sales order reports
database table within sql server
management studio and update the data so
that it looks like the other team
members have also created orders within
the system
great
let's implement the code for the line
chart here like this
this is essentially the same code
implemented for the line chart in the sr
dashboard file the only difference is we
need to change the data source property
to point to the relevant team related
data
so let's change the data source property
appropriately for the line chart
let's run the code
excellent
let's create an order through our
application and see how this affects our
charts
excellent
let's create the data retrieval
functionality for our sm dashboard razor
component
so we are creating the dashboard
functionality for the sales manager so
the bar chart and the line chart are
going to be more complex for the sales
managers dashboard we are adding another
dimension to the data
this means we need to create appropriate
new model classes for the sales manager
reporting functionality
so let's create a model within the
report models folder named location
product category model
so we are going to group by location and
pivot the data
so that the quantity of sales can be
reflected
on our bar chart for each product
category
so to do this we first include the
column by which
we are going to group the data
then we can include columns denoted by
properties for each of the product
categories in our system
so mountain bikes road bikes
camping hiking and boots
let's create a model named month
location model
so with this model we are shaping the
data where the relevant collection of
data is grouped by month of the date
when the relevant orders were made
and as it were pivoting
on the location of where the orders were
made
let's open the i sales order reports
interface and create the relevant method
definitions
let's create a definition for a method
named get qty location product cat data
this method will be responsible for
retrieving the summed up sales order
quantities by location and product
category a bar chart will be used to
display this data
let's create a definition for a method
named get qty per location data this
method will be responsible for
retrieving quantity of sales data
grouped by location a donut chart will
be used to display this data
let's create a definition for a method
named get qty per month location data
this method will be responsible for
retrieving quantity of sales data
grouped by month and location great
let's implement the logic for each of
these methods
great
let's create a razor component named sm
dashboard
let's start by copying the relevant code
from the tl dashboard component
and pasting the code into our sm
dashboard component like this
let's remove the current chart related
code from our sm dashboard.razer file
let's appropriately update the data
retrieval related code so that the
appropriate data is retrieved for our sm
dashboard component
so you can access the code for the sm
dashboard razer file on github at this
location
we are going to add the code for each
chart one at a time
so we can copy the relevant chart code
from this github web page and paste it
into the sm
dashboard.razer file when appropriate
let's start with the bar chart
so let's paste what we have copied from
the relevant github web page here
please feel free to copy the code from
the relevant github web page a link to
the webpage has been included below in
the description
let's include a width property for our
bar chart
you can see here that each chart series
for our first chart pertains to a
product category
so for each chart series element we are
setting the xname property to location
this is the property on which our code
is being grouped the y name property is
set to the relevant product category
so we are declaratively telling the
fusion chart component as it were about
the dimensions of our analytical data
we can adjust the maximum property
so that it suits the sales quantity
values that we currently have saved to
our system
we could bind this property to a
calculated value so that the chart
adjusts appropriately in response to
greater quantities of sales saved to the
system then we are also able to set the
interval for the y-axis here
again this property could be set to a
property value that is calculated on the
fly so that the chart automatically
adapts appropriately in response to the
values saved to the database
i've appropriately altered the data
through ssms a bit offline
don't be afraid to play around with the
data in the sales order report table to
see how the data affects the charts
the code for the donut chart is fairly
basic
the code for the donut chart is
structurally the same as the other donut
charts that we have implemented in this
course
great
so i'm just going to paste the code in
here for the line chart
please feel free to copy the code from
the relevant github webpage for the
implementation of the line chart
and look at that that is excellent
let's alter the data a little bit so
that the relevant order data pertains to
more months of the year
excellent
please consult the sync fusion
documentation for more details about the
charts we are only scraping the surface
here these charts are fantastic and can
be customized in many ways to suit your
requirements
syncfusion has provided excellent
comprehensive documentation on how to
customize the charts there are also many
other types of charts that can be used
in your applications so please dive into
the syncfusion documentation i think
you'll be amazed as i am as to what can
be accomplished using the syncfusion
chart components
and you can see that the syncfusion
layout component and the chart
components are fully responsive on
smaller screens
excellent
in this section of the course
we are going to integrate syncfusion's
diagram component into our application
through the syncfusion diagram component
we are going to implement functionality
so that the sales manager is able to see
the hierarchical structure of the sales
department each node in the diagram
contains a profile picture of the
employee as well as basic information
about the employee
to create this functionality we'll
integrate the syncfusion diagram
component into a razor component
the sales manager will be able to invoke
the relevant razer component
from the main menu of the application
and at a glance see basic information
about each employee and the employee's
position within the organization
the sales manager has admin privileges
so is able to access the employee
management component
and can use the syncfusion data grid to
change employee details so the sales
manager can use the data grid to shuffle
around team members for example change
who a particular sales rep reports to ie
change the team members team leader
the sales manager can then invoke the
razer component containing the sync
fusion diagram that displays the
organizational structure and the change
made to the organizational structure
using the data grid will be reflected in
the diagram component
so let's start by creating a model named
organization model within the models
folder
this model supports data for relevant
employee details
and provides a way for each object in a
list of objects derived from this class
to appropriately reference other objects
of the same type
in a way that a list of objects of this
type
can represent a hierarchical structure
for example the reports2id property will
either store an empty string or an
employee id
if the reports2id property stores an
empty string this means that the
employee that the relevant object
represents is the head of the
organization and doesn't report to
anyone
when the reports to id property for an
object stores an employee id
this means that the relevant employee
that this object represents reports to
the employee whose employee id is
referenced by the reports to property of
the relevant object so in this way each
object of type organization model stored
in a list of objects of this type can be
appropriately related to one another to
form a hierarchical structure
in a bit you'll see how we are able to
wire up a list containing appropriate
objects of the organization model type
to the sync fusion diagram component and
the syncfusion diagram component does
all the heavy lifting as it were to
display an aesthetically pleasing
hierarchical structure containing all
the employees of the organization to the
screen let's create an interface in the
contracts folder named i organization
service
let's create a definition for a method
named get hierarchy that will be
responsible for retrieving data
representing the employee hierarchy for
the sales department ie will return a
list of objects of type organization
model
let's implement the code for the get
hierarchy method
let's first write an appropriate convert
extension method within the conversions
class
so to be explicit i'm going to name our
extension method convert to hierarchy
this extension method simply converts
data retrieved from the employees
database table
which is appropriately joined with
records retrieved from the employee job
titles table to a list of objects of
type organization model
then the implementation for the get
hierarchy method is this simple code
here
let's create a new razor component named
organization
let's provide the appropriate routing
information at the top of the razer file
and an appropriate link within the nav
menu.razer file
so let's navigate to this webpage
in the syncfusion documentation
here we have the organizational tree
structure that we want to implement
within our application
so let's go to the source code for this
demonstration and let's copy the
relevant code to our clipboards
let's appropriately paste the code
copied to our clipboards into our
organization.razer file
so we can see lots of squiggly lines
this is because we haven't yet installed
the syncfusion.blazer.diagram
nuget package so let's do that
let's install version 20.0.1.58
so as to be consistent with the versions
of the sync fusion components that we
have currently installed
excellent
let's write code so that an object of
type i organization service
is injected into our razor component at
runtime
let's make sure that we register the
relevant eye organization service type
for dependency injection
let's write code to override the
uninitialized async blazer lifecycle
event handler method
let's create a property for storing the
data retrieved from our database that
represents the organizational structure
for the sales department
then let's write code within the
uninitialized async method
using our organization service object to
retrieve the relevant data from our
database
and now let's wire up the data source
property appropriately in the data
source settings element to the
organization data property that stores a
list of organization model objects
retrieved from our database
let's let the sf diagram component
component know as it were
which property in the data source
contains the id value and which property
in the data source contains the parent
id value the parent id represents the id
of the employee that the relevant
employee reports to
the id of the relevant employee in the
data source is set to the employee id
property
so this is how the syncfusion diagram
knows as it were about the parent-child
relationship that represents the
employees in the organizational
structure which is of course essential
information for displaying the relevant
data structure as a hierarchical
structure
the next step is to define what
information about the employee will be
presented in each node on the
hierarchical tree structure
so within the node template element
let's include the following information
the employee's first name the employee's
id
the employee's job title
we want each node to contain the
employee's profile image
we don't have a sample based component
base class so let's remove this line of
code at inherits sample base component
then let's remove the code within the
node template element
that we brought over from the demo code
provided in the syncfusion documentation
that is not relevant to our requirement
like this
let's run the code
that is awesome
we are able to navigate around the
diagram that represents our
organizational structure
and view the individual nodes more
closely
we can use the control plus and control
minus keys to zoom in and out
so that we can get a broader view of the
organizational diagram or zoom in for a
closer view of for example the
individual nodes i.e the information of
the individual employees within the
organizational structure
excellent
we don't necessarily need to display the
tree from top to bottom like this
we are able to configure our sf diagram
component component to display from left
to right by adjusting the relevant
setting like this
and we can go over to the employee
management razor component and pretend
we're the sales manager and use the sync
fusion data grid to change the
hierarchical structure of our
organization
excellent
let's clean up our code and remove the
data related code that we brought over
from the demo source
code we are now using our own data
within the organizational tree structure
that is displayed through the sync
fusion diagram component excellent
we have been able to harness the
sophisticated functionality provided by
the syncfusion diagram component easily
and efficiently
all we needed to do was wire up an
appropriate data structure as the data
source to the syncfusion diagram
component
let the syncfusion diagram component
know as it were about the specifics of
the parent-child relationship in our
data structure and customize the nodes
presented by the diagram component to
the ui
we are just scraping the surface of what
can be achieved using the syncfusion
diagram component please check out the
comprehensive documentation provided by
syncfusion to further explore what can
be achieved
so let's say we want to integrate
functionality for the employees of the
sales department so that they can for
example schedule appointments with other
employees or for example schedule client
meetings
to implement this functionality we are
going to integrate syncfusion's
scheduler component into our application
let's start by creating a razor
component named appointments
let's install the syncfusion scheduler
component
so to do this let's install the
syncfusion.blazer.schedule
nuget package
let's install version 20.1.0.58
so that it is consistent with the
versions of the other nuget packages
that we have installed
great
let's navigate to this url in our
browsers
here you can see we have demo source
code provided by syncfusion that
demonstrates some of the core
functionality that we can leverage using
the syncfusion scheduler component
let's go to the source code of the demo
and copy the relevant code like this
into our clipboards
let's paste the code copied to our
clipboard appropriately into our
appointments.razer file let's open the
navmenu.razer file and include an
appropriate link to our appointments
razor component
and when we run our code and navigate to
our appointments razor component we can
see that right out of the box we have
sophisticated functionality already
operational
we are already able to add appointments
to our scheduler at a date and time of
our choosing
we can of course edit and delete the
appointments too
let's modify the current date for our
scheduler to today's date
so you are able to add an appointment to
the scheduler by invoking the most basic
dialog by clicking an appropriate cell
representing a date and time i.e a date
and time at which you wish to schedule
an appointment you are able to
double-click a cell to invoke a dialog
where you are able to enter more
detailed information about the relevant
appointment
you are able to easily change the view
of the scheduler for example you may
wish to see all your appointments for
the week you may wish to view your
appointments in an agenda format
you may wish to view only appointments
for the work week monday to friday or
for the month
so right out of the box we can harness
some very useful functionality
at the moment however
we are only able to save our
appointments
to the scheduler component where the
data only exists in memory
we need a way that we can save our
appointments to our database
through the functionality provided to us
by the syncfusion scheduler component
we are able to apply our own custom code
that will execute when certain events
are fired based on user actions
performed by the user using the
syncfusion scheduler component
so we can for example implement code
that handles crud operations
so for when a user performs certain crud
operations
our code can hook into certain events as
it were triggered by user actions and
ensure that our custom code runs when
these events are triggered
in this way we are able to persist any
changes made regarding appointments on
the user's scheduler component
appropriately to our database
so to do this let's start by creating an
appropriate table within our database we
are of course going to use codefirst
migrations to achieve this
so let's start by creating an
appropriate c-sharp class within the
entities folder
let's create a class named appointment
let's create the relevant properties for
our appointment class
these properties are appropriately
included for our appointment database
table based on the structure that is
used by the syncfusion scheduler
component to represent an appointment in
the scheduler component
so we want our code to be able to easily
retrieve the data for an appointment
created by the user through the
scheduler and save the relevance data to
our appointments database table
note that some of these properties are
nullable
this is important because this gives the
user the ability to fill in data for the
relevant fields regarding a particular
appointment
and other fields that are not relevant
to a particular appointment can be set
to null
let's include the appropriate db set
property within our sales management db
context class
let's create a migration
and let's run the update dash database
command
great
let's create a class within the models
folder named appointment model
we can simply copy the properties from
the appointment entity to our
appointment model class
let's create an interface named i
appointment service
let's create a definition for a method
named get appointments responsible for
retrieving all of the appointments for
the logged on employee
let's create a definition for a method
named add appointment responsible for
adding an appointment created using the
scheduler component to the database for
the logged on employee
let's create a definition for a method
named update appointment responsible for
updating the data for an appointment
modified using the scheduler component
in the database for the logged on
employee
let's create a definition for a method
named delete appointment responsible for
removing the data for an appointment
removed using the scheduler component
from the database for the logged on
employee
let's implement the logic for a method
definition in a class named appointment
service
let's include a constructor in the
appointment service class and ensure
that our constructor includes a
parameter of type sales management db
context
so that an object of this type is
injected into our constructor at runtime
let's also create a private read-only
member variable that references the
injected sales management db context
object
oops we have a typo here let's remove
the extra e from delete appointment
first from our i appointment service
interface and then from the appointment
service class
let's first implement code for the add
appointment method
firstly let's create a convert overload
extension method within the conversions
class that as it were converts an object
of type appointment model to an object
of type appointment
then let's write code within the add
appointment method to first convert an
argument passed into this method of type
appointment model to type appointment
and then let's write code to add the
converted object to the database through
ef call functionality like this
before we create the code for the get
appointments method let's write a
convert overload extension method that
as it were transforms the list of
objects of type appointment to a list of
objects of type appointment model
then the code that we need to implement
for our get appointments method is
simply this line of code
then let's implement the following code
for the update appointment method
and the delete appointment method
note that we have not yet implemented
the login functionality for our
application so for now let's hard code
the employee id to nine
which relates to the sales rep benjamin
lucas to simulate that benjamin lucas is
the current logged on user we need to
update the convert extension method that
converts as it were an object of type
appointment model to an object of type
appointment
this will ensure that when an
appointment is added to the system that
at the moment the appointment will as it
were be made by benjamin lucas
we must also include a wear filter like
this
within the get appointments method to
filter the retrieved appointments by the
employee id of benjamin lucas
let's open the appointments.raiser file
let's write code to override the
uninitialized async blazer lifecycle
event handler method
let's write code so that an object of
type i appointment service is injected
into our razor component at
runtime let's make sure that we
appropriately register the appointment
service type for dependency injection
let's create a property that will serve
as the data source for our scheduler
component
let's write the code within our
uninitialized async method to retrieve
the relevant appointment data from our
database
let's appropriately set the data source
property for our scheduler component
let's set the t value property of the sf
schedule element to tell the syncfusion
scheduler component as it were about the
type of objects stored in the relevant
data source
let's also update the t-value property
of the schedule events element to the
appointment model type
let's remove some of the code that we
don't need for our requirement
and tidy up the code a little bit
so now how do we hook into an
appropriate event so that our
crowd-related code fires
when the relevant event is raised by the
scheduler component
this is actually very simple within the
schedule events element we can set the
on action begin property to an event
handler method
that we are going to create
our method will of course contain the
code that we want to execute when the
relevant event is raised
we can also write code that we want
executed when our code within the method
that handles the on action begin event
has completed
we can do this by setting the action
completed property to an event handler
method that we are going to write
so let's first write the code for the
method that handles the on action begin
event
firstly let's write an if statement to
check what type of action has been
executed by the user of the syncfusion
scheduler component
so if
args.actiontype
equals to the
actiontype.eventcreateenum value
we know that the user is adding an
appointment
so we are able to retrieve the
appointment data entered by the user
with this line of code
and then we can add the relevant
appointment data to the database using
our appointment service object like this
then let's create the code for the
method to handle the event
that is fired when the code within the
on action begin async method completes
so we only want code in this method to
fire when the user creates an
appointment
let's set the at ref attribute to a
property that we'll create
so that we are able to reference the
syncfusion scheduler component in our
code using the relevant property
let's create the relevant property
then let's write code
to retrieve all appointments for the
logged on employee
and let's also write code to refresh the
scheduler component
let's run the code
and add an appointment firstly through
the basic dialog
we can launch this basic dialog by
clicking on one of the cells
let's check our database
excellent
so now let's write code so that when a
user updates an appointment that the
changes are saved to the database
the code for this is really intuitive
let's test the code
excellent
we are able to update any of the fields
associated with an appointment and our
changes are now saved to the database
let's implement code so that we are able
to delete an appointment from the
database using the scheduler component
excellent
and you can see that we are now able to
perform crud operations through our
syncfusion scheduler component and any
changes we make are persisted to our
database
so at this point we have written all the
functionality for our application
however for certain functionality we
have hard-coded the logged on employee
id to imitate a particular employee
being logged onto the system
we want certain functionality in our
application to be available
based on the context of who is logged
onto the system
we want certain razor components in our
application to be available to certain
employees when they are logged into the
system conversely we want certain razor
components to not be available to
certain employees when they are logged
into the system
for example we only want an
administrator to be able to access the
data grid whereby an administrator can
perform crowd operations on employee
data
the sales manager has been given
administrative privileges in our system
so the sales manager is therefore able
to perform crowd operations on employee
data through the use of the data grid
component
we only want sales reps to be able to
create orders in the system on behalf of
clients
so only sales reps will be able to
access the product catalog razer
component
we want a dashboard displayed to the
logged on user
based on the relevant user's position in
the sales department i.e based on
whether a user is a sales rep team
leader or the sales manager for example
we want sales reps to only see those
charts in their dashboard that are of
relevance to sales reps
the diagram that displays the
organizational hierarchy will only be
available to the sales manager
the scheduler is available to all
employees
but only the appointments added by the
logged-on employee will be available to
the logged-on employee
so how can we achieve this contextual
behavior for users logged on to our
application
the answer is through providing
appropriate login functionality
where our application can authenticate
the user when the user logs onto the
system and authorization can be granted
for the logged on user to be able to
access certain functionality in the
application conversely the logged-on
user may be unauthorized to access other
parts of the application
so to achieve this we are going to
integrate microsoft identity
functionality into our application
very basically microsoft identity
provides an infrastructure for
registration and login functionality
using the microsoft identity technology
will make it easy to add login and
registration functionality to our
application and provide the
authentication and authorization
functionality
that we have just discussed
so at the point at which we created our
blazer server project we could have
chosen to integrate microsoft identity
into our application
we chose not to integrate microsoft
identity into our application at that
point but we are still able to integrate
microsoft identity into our application
even if we choose not to do so at the
point of creating the initial project
for our application
in this section of the course that is
exactly what we are going to do
we are going to go through each step
that needs to be performed in order to
integrate microsoft identity into an
already existing blazer server
application that does not yet have the
microsoft identity technology integrated
for the performance of login
registration authentication and
authorization functionality
let's go through this step by step
so the first step
is to make our sales management db
context class inherit from the generic
identitydbcontext class which accepts
the identity user type as a type
argument we are doing this because we
are going to house the microsoft
identity database tables within the same
database as where the database tables of
our application reside
we could create an entirely new
dbcontext class for our microsoft
identity functionality but our
application is self-contained and
monolithic so in the interests of
simplicity let's simply create the
microsoft identity tables within the
database we are already using for our
application
as you can see we have a red squiggly
line here
if we position our mouse pointers
appropriately and press ctrl period
we can see that we are missing the
installation for an essential nuget
package
microsoft dot asp.net core dot identity
dot entity framework core
we can install the latest version of
this nuget package at this point by
clicking on the find and install latest
version menu option presented to us
through visual studio
so let's do that
and visual studio has done the
appropriate installation
and has also included the appropriate
using directive to the relevant
namespace at the top of our code
microsoft.asp.net core
dot identity dot entity framework core
great
the next step is to add the identity
templates representing the functionality
that we wish to integrate into our
application for example login
registration and logout functionality
so to do this let's right click on the
project node in our solution explorer
window and select add new scaffolded
item select identity on the left here
click add
you can see that we are presented with a
variety of files that we can integrate
into our application
identity provides a suite of rich
functionality but we are currently only
interested in registration and login
functionality
so to include the appropriate identity
features into our application
let's check the check boxes next to
account slash login accounts log out and
account slash register
the next step is to click the plus
button next to data context class
our application has a monolithic
architecture
it is a self-contained application so we
are going to integrate the identity
database tables into the same database
as the database where our application
database tables reside
so in the dialog that has just popped up
let's enter the name of our already
existing dbcontext class
sales management db context
let's click the add button on this
dialog
then let's click the add button on the
main dialog
at this point if you haven't followed
the steps
where we made our sales management db
context class
inherit from the identity db context
class an exception will be thrown
we have made our sales management db
context class
inherit from the identity db context
class so we have no problems
we must however make some adjustments to
our program.cs class
so let's go to the program.cs class
visual studio has added in code add db
context which is causing duplication of
code so let's remove this add db context
code here
let's paste our original connection
string related code over the connection
string code that visual studio has added
to program.cs
then you can see here that visual studio
has added code to program.cs that is
appropriate for integrating microsoft
identity into our application
we must have the add default identity
method being called here for simplicity
let's modify this code here
options.signin dot require confirmed
account equals true
to read
options.signin dot require confirmed
account equals false
by setting this to false we are telling
the identity system as it were not to
include functionality
where the user has to confirm the user's
identity by clicking a link sent to the
user's email address great so let's
create a migration that will generate
the necessary code for generating the
identity tables in our database
great
let's run our migration code by running
the update database command
excellent
the next step is we are going to create
code to register certain employees with
the identity system whose records exist
within the employees table
through our code these employees will be
put into certain roles for example the
sr identity role will contain employees
who are sales reps the tl role will
contain employees who are team leaders
the sm role will contain the sales
manager the admin role will contain
employees
who are able to perform cred operations
on employee details the sales manager
will be included in both the sm role and
the admin role
so firstly let's generate a migration
notice that this migration class doesn't
contain any code logic but just the
structure for a migration class
so we are going to create the code for
this migration class to register certain
employees with the identity system and
add the employees to their appropriate
identity roles in the interests of time
i've already prepared the code for this
off screen so we are going to copy the
code from this github location
a link to this location is available
below in the description of this video
and paste the code appropriately into
our migration class here
so each user and each role in the
identity tables must be associated with
a unique gurd global unique identifier
in the identity tables guides are used
as primary key values
so let's generate new goods for these
constant string values
let's replace the goods that i generated
for this sample code with newly
generated goods
an easy way to do that is to navigate to
this url
we can then type in the number of goods
we would like to generate so we want 11
goods
we can then generate the goods and copy
them to our clipboards
let's paste the goods into our code here
and comment them out
then let's replace the existing goods
assigned to our constant values with the
new goods
that we have just generated
great
let's paste the code in for the up
method like this
notice that for the sake of simplicity
the password for each of the employees
that this code will register with the
identity system will be password one
with the p capitalized and an
exclamation mark character so password
one exclamation mark is the password
let's bring in the microsoft dot asp.net
core dot identity namespace
let's copy the code for the private
methods that are being called from
within the up method and paste these
private methods appropriately into our
migration class
let's copy the code for the down method
and appropriately paste the code into
our down method here
let's paste in the code for the private
methods that are being called from
within the down method
let's invoke the package manager console
window
and run the update database command
let's view our database within sql
server management studio
excellent
so in order to include identity role
based functionality in our application
we need to include the add roles method
like this here within our registration
functionality regarding identity
we must also include a call to these
methods in our program dot cs class so
that our application knows as it were to
include this identity middleware in our
application so please appropriately
include the following code app.use
dot
authentication
authorization
the next step is to ensure that an
anti-forgery token is passed to the
client
this anti-forgery token can then be
passed to the server with each client
request
the benefit of this is that our code
will be able to verify that the client
accessing our code is a trusted client
we don't want just any client to be able
to access our code
we only want trusted clients accessing
our code
one of the ways that hackers can
overcome our security is through
cross-site scripting
so the next step is we need to include
anti-forgery token functionality in our
application
to do this let's first add a class named
tokenprovider to our data folder
let's include string properties within
our token provider class
the xsrf string property
and the refresh token property
so let's open the underscore host dot cs
html file and write code so that an
object of type microsoft
dot asp.net core
dot anti forgery dot i anti forgery is
injected into this page at runtime
this is where we are going to generate
the token and pass the token into our
application
let's write code to use the injected
object to request a token
let's create an object named tokens
derived from our tokenprovider class
and then assign the returns token to the
xsrf token property of our tokenprovider
object
within the component element
let's add a property named param
initial state
and set its value to the tokens object
this is how we are passing our token to
our application
we are passing the tokens object to the
app razer component let's appropriately
update the app razer component
let's write code to inject an object of
type token provider into our appraiser
component at runtime
let's include a using statement
that references the namespace of where
our tokenprovider class resides within
the
underscoreimports.razer file
the cascading authentication state
element wraps the router element
we need to change the root view element
to an authorized root view element
we can remove this line of code here
so when the appraiser component loads up
we want to assign the initial state
parameter that we are passing down from
the underscore host dot cs html page and
we are going to set
the xs rf token property of the token
provider object injected into this razor
component at runtime
to the xsrf token property of the
tokenprovider object passed into the
initial state parameter
next let's create our own login display
component note that if we had included
identity functionality at the point when
we created our blazer server project a
file for the login display component
would have been generated for us by
default
in our particular scenario we are going
to create our own login display
component
so let's create a razor component named
login display
let's write the code for our login
display component
so here we have code that is responsible
for injecting a token provider object
into our component at runtime our html
code is wrapped in an authorized view
element
if the relevant user is authorized a
welcome message
and a logout button are shown to the
user
if the user is not authorized a register
button and a login button is presented
to the user notice that we have a hidden
input field included in the html code
our token provider object's xsrf token
property is stored within the hidden
text field
then we need to reference the log and
display eraser component appropriately
within the main layout raiser file
next let's add a razor component to our
shared directory named redirect to login
let's include this code within the
redirect to login raise a file
as the name suggests this code is used
to redirect a user to the login page
and that is basically it
let's see if we can log into our
application
oops what have we done wrong
we have not registered our token
provider type for dependency injection
let's go to the program.cs file and
write the code for this
let's run the code
great we are presented with the default
login screen
provided by identity let's log in as one
of the employees who is a team leader
henry andrews
great
but we haven't created any authorization
functionality in our application yet
so by default
anyone can just access any functionality
within the system
so we can click the log out link to log
out of our application like this
let's write code so that the links to
our razer components are only accessible
to relevant employees
so let's restrict the visibility of the
link to the tl dashboard razor component
within the nav menu razer component
so that it can only be seen by members
of the tl role
tl of course stands for team leader
we can achieve this by wrapping the
relevant link in the authorized view
element
we can then set the elements
roles property to tl like this note that
if we wanted to include more than one
role value within the roles property all
we would have to do is separate the
relevant values by a comma so we would
provide a comma delimited string
containing the relevant roles
let's run the code
you can see that the tl dashboard is not
visible when we first launch the
application however if we log in as
henry andrews who is a team leader and
therefore a member of the tl role
we can now see the link to the tl
dashboard razer component in the main
menu
excellent
the moment we log out the link to the tl
dashboard razer component is no longer
available
if we log in as benjamin lucas who is a
sales rep
and not a team leader
once he has been authenticated
we still can't see the link to the tl
dashboard component
because he is not a team leader and
therefore not a member of the tl
identity role
let's restrict the link to the sr
dashboard razor component so that only
sales reps ie members of the sr roll can
see this link
so if we launch the application
we can no longer see the link to the sr
dashboard razer component
if we log in as a sales rep
there it is
great
if we log in as henry andrews a team
leader
he is not able to see the link to the sr
dashboard raise a component
because he is not a sales rep and not a
member of the sr identity role so in
order for the correct data to be added
to the system and the correct data to be
retrieved from the system pertaining to
the logged on employee
let's write code to replace the
hard-coded employee ids for relevant
functionality with the employee id of
the logged on employee so how can we do
this
so the data we have registered in the
asp.net users identity table contains
employee email addresses which of course
are unique
and they match up to the relevant email
addresses saved for employees in the
employees table
our code is going to use the email
address retrieved through identity when
a user logs on to the system to query
the employees table in order to as it
were retrieve the logged on employees
employee object
then the employee's id
can be read from the relevant employee
object and we can use the employee id
value appropriately in our code rather
than a hard-coded value
to do this let's create an extension
method within the conversions class
named getemployee object
this first parameter is of type
system.security.com
principle this will allow our code to
call the get employee object extension
method on the user object of type
system.security.claims.claims principle
that will be available to our code once
a user has been authenticated after the
user logs onto the system we'll look at
the user object in just a bit
so we can use the user objects
identity.name property which returns the
email address registered in the asp.net
users identity table for the employees
that we registered through running the
relevant migration that we created
earlier
we can use this email address which is
also the user's username to query the
employees table and return the
appropriate employee object to the
calling code like this
great
so let's first change the code in the
order service class so that the relevant
employee id
is no longer hard coded to the employee
id pertaining to benjamin lucas
so we need to be able to access the user
object which is an object that will be
available once a user is authenticated
to gain access to the user object
let's first create a parameter within
the constructor of the order service
class of type authentication state
provider
let's create a member variable to
reference the injected object
let's create a private method
that first gets a reference to the user
object like this
and then we can call our get employee
object extension method on the user
object and return the relevant employee
object to the calling code like this
within the create order method let's
call the get logged on employee method
to reference the employee object of the
logged on employee and replace the
hard-coded value of 9
with the logged on employees employee id
great
let's create the same logic for the
sales order report service class like
this
and let's do the same for the
appointment service class
when we ran our migration that
registered certain employees
we registered the following employees
within the identity system
we registered bob jones the sales
manager as a member of the sm role
and the admin role
we registered henry andrews who is a
team leader and a member of the tl role
we registered all the members of henry's
team
i.e the sales reps benjamin lucas olivia
mills
sarah henderson and noah robinson so now
if we log in as henry andrews
great the hard-coded employee id 3 is no
longer used to retrieve the relevant
data the id for the logged on employee
is instead used excellent
the same is true for benjamin lucas
excellent
let's login as olivia mills
and we don't have much data for olivia
mills
but the system is reflecting the correct
data for olivia mills who is a sales rep
let's login as sarah henderson
great and you can play around with the
data in the sales order reports table
to create more interesting data for the
sales reps
let's go to the nav menu razer component
and appropriately write code so that
only the functionality appropriate to
the logged on user is available to the
relevant user
excellent
let's log in as bob jones the sales
manager
and operate the application from his
perspective
excellent
and you can see we have now
appropriately integrated microsoft
identity into our application where
appropriate authentication and
authorization functionality has now been
implemented
we are currently appropriately making
the relevant links
in the main menu visible to logged on
users based on the roles to which they
belong
at present however a user could
currently still access any razor
component despite not having the
appropriate privileges
by simply typing in the url of the
relevant razer component
so to prevent this
we can also restrict access within the
razer components themselves
one way of doing this
is by appropriately including the
authorized attribute within the relevant
razor component like this
and now access to these razor components
are prohibited for unauthorized users
excellent
just to add an air of authenticity to
our fictional company i've created a
basic logo very quickly in photoshop for
our fictional company outdoor excellence
or oexl for short
you can download the image from this
location
of course you're welcome to create your
own company and company logo for the
application but if you'd like you can
download the one i created from this
location on github
to present the logo to the user when the
user first launches the application
let's include this code within the index
raiser component please feel free to
copy the code from github
let's also include the logo within the
nav menu razer component
let's open the login display razer
component and style the buttons for the
login logout and registration
functionality
let's remove the about link from the
main layout razer component
let's include the login display element
appropriately within the nav menu razer
component so that the login and
registration related buttons are
available on mobile screen sizes within
the main menu note we are including the
d
sm
none bootstrap class in the container
element that contains the login display
razor component reference so that the
relevant buttons only show up in the nav
menu razor component when the app is
running on mobile devices i.e when the
app is only being presented on small
screens
let's add some meaningful icons provided
by font awesome to the links in our main
menu ie in the nav menu razer component
let's include an appropriate font
awesome link element within our
underscorelayout.cshtml page which will
give us access to the font awesome icons
font awesome cdn is the easiest way to
get font awesome on our web application
let's search the font awesome website
like this for some appropriate icons and
appropriately include them within our
nav menu razer component for our links
great
and lastly i want to import the
quicksand google font from within the
site.css file and reference this font in
the font-family css property for our
pages html and body elements
excellent
and that's it
that is our application finished
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
i've thoroughly enjoyed creating this
course and i hope you've enjoyed going
through it with me
if you have gone through the whole
course congratulations you are now able
to build a sophisticated blazer server
application using sophisticated
syncfusion components and microsoft
identity i hope to see you again soon
thank you and take care